[музика]
Усі хто навчають нам світ відкривають
від нашої долі мають ключі то наші
поважні кмітливі відважні важливі вони
як ніхто на землі
шкільні вчителі шкільні вчителі важливі
вони
на землі
[музика]
шкільний на землі
кроками учитель навчає нас жити
підказує кроки великий Малій Щоб мрії
своїми на радість здійснили шляхи
відкривають для нас вчителі шкільні
вчителі вчителі вчителі важливі вони як
ніхто на землі
вчителі шкі
льні були на землі тож добре коли ми
і Бави у різних куточках на нашій землі
про наших шкільних вчителів пам'ятали
вам шановний від нас вчителі
шкільній і вчителі
шкіри
важливі вони
на землі шкі
[музика]
льні іде
ї якщо вони на землі шкільні вчителі
шкільні вчителі
шкільні вчителі шкільні вчителі важливі
як
це вони на землі
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні освітяни управлінці
педагоги Ми раді вітати вас на наші
серпневій конференції на локації для
ректорів директорів закладів вищої та
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
тема локації навчання педагогічної еліти
з програмою заходу ви ознайомлені також
її надіслано в чат нашої конференції
наша сумконференція буде йти в записі та
одночасно транслюватися на YouTube
каналі матеріали вебінару після
завершення заходу також будуть розміщені
на сайті інституту модернізації змісту
освіти та Міністерства освіти і науки
України
девітального мотиваційного слова
Запрошуємо
бажанкова Євгена Володимировича
кандидата наук з фізичного виховання і
спорту директора інституту модернізації
змісту освіти будь ласка Євген
Володимирович
знаходиться на зага конференції яка
знаходиться сьогодні в Бучі і тому він
ще по дорозі я думаю що в кінці нашої
наради від нас ще приєднається і тому ти
розпочати нашу
освітянську продовження нашої
свічанської конференції освіти
освітянами зламані у війні і наша
сьогодні локація для ректорів директорів
закладів вищої та післядипломної
педагогічної освіти на початку ви
послухали пісню хочеться подякувати
автору цієї пісні цю пісню і кліп
підготувала для нас наша працівниця і
член кореспондент Академії Наук Професор
наша Пушкарьова Тамара Олексіївна так що
в нас спеціально для нашої конференції
від щиро їдять Шановні колеги сьогодні
на порозі нові навчальній рік Ви всі вже
слухали сьогодні виступ і міністра і
ряд виступаючих на самій конференції де
піднімалися Ті такі важливі питання які
ми сьогодні також повинні розглянути на
нашій локації
і розпочинаємо
навчальний рік дуже великій і страшний
для нас на нашій країні період на тлі
широкомасштабної жорстокої агресії Росії
проти України вони зруйновано дуже
багато шкіл а частина людей опинилася в
окупації або у вимушені еміграції але
найстрашніше від зброї окупанта не
тільки наші воїни а пізнавалими
зруйнованих будинків умирають і тому ми
розуміємо що крім військових засобів
сьогодні Які робить наша наші збройні
сили України на фронтах дуже важлива
сьогодні і інформаційна і культурна
інформаційний культурний контент який
сьогодні ми повинні представляти
нашій мові і основне те що ми як
ідеологи ідеологи освіти повинні внести
в школу той продукт який сьогодні вкрай
необхідно вчора Може хтось з вас був
тоже брав участь ми проводили велику
таку конференцію де обговорили зміни до
нашого навчальних програм основи
здоров'я захисту України історія фізична
культура громадянська освіта та інші де
були створені робочі групи які працювали
які проаналізували весь весь всі ці
навчальній програмі і вилучили все те що
зв'язується з російським тому що саме
російські сьогодні воно приносить
глибокий біль і супротив у наших серцях
раз воно приносить супротив наших серцях
у нас немає можливості використання і
білоруського контенту контенції вивчення
його у шкільному курсі І ми його
вилучили і ми з вами разом з вами і
особливо інституту післядипломної освіти
вищий педагогічні ВУЗи коли ми працюємо
сьогодні з вчителями коли ми працюємо
студентами Можемо і повинні ці зміни які
є в навчальних програмах шостих 11
класів початкової школи якраз донести
сьогодні і до студентів і до
освіта це ключовий соціальний продукт і
соціальний інститут ефективне вирішення
будь-яких проблем що стоять перед нашим
суспільством неможливо без залучення
освіти і тому сьогодні який висвіт еліта
освіти - це перш за все вчителі ми
знаємо що наші вчителі - це еліта освіти
і перед нами стоять дуже і дуже важливі
завдання Сьогодні для того щоб
сформулювати
інтелектуальну еліту це разом з тим це
інституція інститут післядипломної
освіти уже коли працюють з підвищенням
кваліфікації але в основному це
педагогічні ВУЗи які сьогодні готовлять
заміну готовлять нових вчителів які
сьогодні прийдуть у навчальні заклади
питання підвищення статусу вчителя
Шановні колеги ми з вами розглядали коли
Минулого року у Харкові
наш Міністр освіти Сергій Миколайович
презентував великий
такий проект освіта України 30
національні Технопарк підвищення
діяльності освіти і дійсно вони
розглядали ми цих Технопарк було
виділено 7 хабіб серед них ті які ми
повинні сьогодні реалізувати для того
щоб ми допомогли нашим якраз вчителям
нашим дітям сьогодні реалізувати ті
питання які є і під час обговорення
національно-освітнього технопарку було
якраз обговорення проходило з чотирьох
таких базових компонентів один з цих
чотирьох базових компонентів Я пропоную
сьогодні на нашій локації розглянути і
цей основний такий компонент який ми
сьогодні будемо згадати носить назву
кардинальне оновлення системи підготовки
та супроводу компетентні вчителя для
нової української школи тому саме якраз
ми запросили сьогодні на нашу локацію
ректорів педагогічних вузів тому що і
надалі і вже і в вересні місяці ми
будемо проводити наради спільними
зусиллями тому що педагогічні ВУЗи
сьогодні готовлять кадри які після того
ми з вами будемо підвищувати
кваліфікацію знайомити їх е-е з тими
матеріалами із новими народками які
сьогодні є у педагогічній спільноті і
тому-то вищий навчальний заклади
сьогодні відіграють також велику роль Ми
сьогодні запросили і ми з вами ті
питання про які ми сьогодні я вам
договорити ми розглянемо більше
вдосконало коли буде розглядати ті чи
інші питання тому то представники вищих
навчальних закладів також поділяться з
нами і від того інформацію як вони
сьогодні у наш час сьогодні можете
реалізувати ті завдання які своя
сьогодні перед нами сьогодні заклади
післядипломної педагогічної освіти це
основна база підготовки і чому саме тому
що від них залежить Яким є суспільство
високого елітного рівня або воно буде
недоро- особливо під час правового
режиму воєнного стану в Україні
заклади освіти ви бачите одна
таблички яку основну роботу вони
сьогодні відіграють і мені хочеться
подякувати своїм колегам тому що в той
період коли були ліквідовані методичні
служби іменно в районах коли виникає
питання підвищення кваліфікації одне
ліквідували інші центри які створили не
виконують тих основних завданнях які
стоять сьогодні для того щоб працювати з
вчителями тому основні напрямки роботи
які сьогодні відіграють регіональні
заклади освіти це координація діяльності
освітніх установ підготовка вчителів
розробка освітніх програм методичних
рекомендацій навчальних посібників і так
далі І так далі І так далі дуже багато
завдань які які сьогодні
вирішують самі самі інститути тому
сьогодні на
конференції піднімалися основні питання
які Над якими проектами Ми сьогодні
будемо працювати які моделі сьогодні
будуть працювати у школі тому що війна
вносить свої корективи керівник тому що
і ви уважно коли слухали що в нас
сьогодні і учне навчання і змішане
навчання дистанційне навчання
індивідуальна форма навчання Разом з тим
навчання тих
наших дітей які знаходяться тимчасово
виїхали за кордон І сьогодні ми хочемо і
працюємо над тим щоб як донести ті
матеріали які освітній програмі які є
тим дітям які знаходяться на тимчасово
окупованих територій щоб вони вчилися по
наших програмах по наших підручниках по
наших посібниках і так далі І так далі І
так далі сьогодні
ми говоримо те що
навчальні заклади що стосуються
навчально-методичного забезпечення
підручників
підготовлені Я вже вчора також говорив
вашим колегам що з першого по 11 клас
всі підручники і в паперовому вигляді і
разом з тим і впаде в версіях розміщення
на сайтах інституту на сайтах
міністерства в нас виникала була
проблема тільки сказати Будь ласка але
завдяки тому що велася велика робота із
видавництвами видавництва пішли на
зустріч із понеділками будемо
розміщувати електронні версії
підручників уже на сайтах інституту і
Міністерства і діти вчителі і батьки
зможуть користуватися І
дійсно працювати з тим матеріалом які
сьогодні є ви знаєте що період війни і
інститути і разом з тим навчальні
заклади стикнулися з тим що дуже багато
дітей вчителів одні виїхали за кордон
Інші виїхали на з території яка
тимчасово окупована інші регіони України
ті які знаходяться на тій території де
недавно ще Чи були бойові дії і так далі
і тому основна така завдання Конституції
Ми також про це будемо сьогодні говорити
це психологічна підтримка це робота
психологічних служб і тому сьогодні
треба велику увагу звернути на те що
проводити відповідну роботу починаючи і
дітей і батьків і вчителів для того щоб
вони працювали із психологом і в нас
дійсно розроблений великий курс перша
психологічна допомога учасникам
освітнього процесу за ініціативи першої
леді Олени Зеленського про це тоже Ми
сьогодні розкажемо на сайті інституту ми
підготували до серпневої конференції
великий такий дальше е-е методичних
матеріалів з психологічної допомоги який
спокійно зайти подивитися ці матеріали і
використовувати в своєму навчальному
процесі Разом з тим для допомоги
вчителів ви знаєте і по психології і
разом з тим і про побудови кар'єру і
разом з ним ви знаєте що підготовлено
дуже багато матеріалів навчальних
програм посібників і так далі які також
розміщені будуть на сайтах інституту і
Міністерства де ви можете використати їх
для роботи своїми своїми педагогами і
разом з тим останній такий ми говоримо
про те що таке в обіход на нашої
діяльності увійшли освітні хати які
питати сьогодні і міністр говорив ці
хаби створюються і за кордоном і разом з
тим на території наших областей - Це ці
центри які будуть на допомоги і
психологічної допомоги і методичної
допомоги всім тим хто хоче
узнати дуже багато нового і разом з тим
прийти і отримати
І на завершення Мені хочеться подякувати
всім освітянські спільноті за ті умови
золоту роботу яку вони сьогодні
виконують крім освітнього процесу Ми
сьогодні в освітяни віднести вибухи і
гусит забезпечують внутрішні потреби не
тільки наших воїнів аж життє необхідні
потреби і переселенці та біженців з
окупованих територій Ми сьогодні
освітнього армія І ми надіємося що ми
спільно з вами ті негаразди ті проблеми
ті ризики які сьогодні є ми успішно їх
виконаємо виконаємо і 1 вересня ми
підемо на навчання І дійсно сьогодні
міністр започаткував Усі ми бачили з
вами флешмоб повертаюся до навчання
дійсно Нам треба зробити максимум зусиль
щоб наші діти 1 вересня повернулися до
навчання і це буде залежати від нас яку
модель навчання вибо навчальний заклад
це вже буде залежить від
тих умов якими в якому знаходиться сам
навчальний заклад але щоб кожна дитина
мене загубили ні одну дитину щоб кожна
дитина де вона не була вона прийшла
навчання різні різними моделями і це
наші з вами основне завдання Дякую за
уваги і сьогодні коли ми розпочинаємо
перший В нас такий виступ ви знаєте що
питання кадрового кадрового забезпечення
сьогодні дуже сьогодні актуальні тому що
створення і децентралізації і так далі
ми знаємо як наші кадрі коли
призначаються на деякі посади деякі не
Ну вам сказати що не дуже знають ті
матеріальні ті матеріали ту інформацію
що дальше робити як керувати навчальним
закладом і тому
наш структурі нашого інституту ми
створили великий такий у нас є
національна школа яка буде займатися
підготовкою управлінських кадрів і керує
цією школою В нас може доктор знову
професор ви ви мабуть І знаєте її тому
що вона довгий час працювала і ректором
інституту і директора Департаменту блока
Наталія Іванівна Я надаю слово Наталію
Іванівна вам це раз досконало розкаже
про це питання і про впливу національну
управлінських кадрів яке є в нашому
місті
Доброго дня шановні колеги А ми з вами
глибоко усвідомлюємо що успіх наших
реформ і розвиток освіти у значній мірі
залежить від рівня професійної
компетентності керівників закладів
освіти зокрема ми акцентуємо увагу на
роботі закладів загальної середньої
освіти саме для того щоб підтримати
керівників для того щоб дати можливість
здобувати нові знання виробляти нові
компетентності і створена національна
школа управлінських кадрів про нашу
інституті яка має завдання пошуку
підтримки і навчання резерву
управлінських кадрів що є дуже важливе
підготовка нової генерації сучасних
керівників підтримка науково-методичний
супровід професійного встановлення
новопризначених директорів підтримка
професійного розвитку досвідчених
керівників в умовах нової викликів
Звичайно що ми маємо на меті допомагати
громадам формування дієвого резерву
управлінських кадрів та формувати
національну спільноту керівників
говорив які будуть задіяні у підготовці
резерву майбутніх керівників
Отже успішна робота школи управлінських
кадрів ми вважаємо може бути лише за
умови
співпраці
із нашими партнерами
школа управлінських кадрів сьогодні
ефективно взаємодія із провідними
українськими вченими та управлінцями з
питань сучасної освітнього менеджменту і
кращих управлінських практик Сьогодні ми
маємо перший результати роботи будемо
детальніше говорити про Корпорацію Intel
схил освої не вийшов і корпорація ландте
як Київ ми вдячні і фірмові Microsoft
також наші партнери є Франції
з плідно співпрацюємо з Україною
фінським проєктом фінська підтримка
реформи української школи навчаємося
разом асоціації інноваційного та
цифрової освіти благодійний фонд фонд
освітніх ініціатив
національна школа управлінських кадрів
вже сьогодні пропонує для наших
майбутніх керівників і для
новопризначених керівників і всіх
бажаючих керівників такі програми це
освітня програма підвищення кваліфікації
на 150 годин для працюючих керівників
освітня програма підготовки резерву
керівних кадрів типова освітня програма
навчання новопризначених керівників
закладів освіти програма один модуль ми
свідомо виділяємо щоб наші керівники
бачили що програма саме 30 годин Це один
кредит Intel steels і не вийшло програма
30 годин лідер Марії яку ми реалізують
спільно із Франклін хобі програма 30
годин освіта для дітей раннього та
дошкільного віку освіти піклування
менеджмент освітня програма для навчання
керівників основи психологічного
консультування Для прикладу програми
навчального резерву керівників пропонує
такі модулі І власне свої назви ви
розумієте який зміст закладений у
навчанні перш за все це трансформація
національної системи освіти в уміння в
умовах
адміністративно-територіальної реформи і
децентралізації влади управління нової
української школи менеджмент освітнього
процесу організації безпечної
дорогосвітнього середовища інноваційні
технології як із освіти в умовах
автономії психологію управління закладу
освіти що є дуже важливою про що вище
говорив шановний Юрій Іванович навчання
дітей з особливими потребами
інформаційно цифрова компетентність
керівника закладу освіти успішна
лідерство зарубіжний досвід
говорячи про нашу спільну співпрацю
свійськими партнерами можемо вже
сьогодні звітуватися про те що спільно
створено 90 годин 91 типову програму
підвищення кваліфікації для
новопризначених керівників закладів
загальної середньої освіти
модулі програми це перш за все нові ролі
директора школи в контексті провадження
нуш створення якісної управлінської та
освітньої системи основи концепції
закладу загальної середньої освіти щодо
забезпечення комфортної безпечного
освітнього середовища Ми дякуємо нашої
австрійським партнерам за ефективності
праці і результати які ми вже отримали
наші співпраця з ранкові дівкишин теж
має свої позитивні результати ми
створили модуль 30 години проект лідер в
мені
теми які пропонуються для вивчення це 4
хронічні проблеми освітнього процесу
рішення парадигма цілісної людини
рішення чотири правила успішних лідерів
моделювання викликає довіру характери
компетенції спонукають до авторитету та
довіри пошук шляху створює порядок не
вимагаючи його достовірна стратегія
Також ми сьогодні його можемо говорити і
мій виступ продовжує наше партнери з
Intel Corporation ми спільно
відпрацювали і провели вже за
англомовної 30-годинною програмою і
інтелекс іnnovation онлайн навчання на
базі нашого інституту яке пройшло 53
керівники закладів загальної середньої
освіти викладачі закладі післядипломної
педагогічної освіти сьогодні дякуючи
тісні співпраці з фірмою лантехнішинс
завершується переклад матеріалів проекту
Intel українську мову і ми плануємо
найближчим часом проведення 30-годинних
курсів підвищення кваліфікації для
керівників для резерву керівників а
також педагогічних працівників за
програмою інтелекс hillsation і з
вересня 22-го року Отже Шановні колеги я
окреслила лише окремі ключові питання
роботи національної школи управлінських
кадрів Ми плануємо зробити багато її вже
перший результат сподіваємось на плідну
співпрацю з нашими інститутами
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
оскільки навчальні резерву педагогічних
кадрів і керівних кадрів передбачає
стажування на базі кращих директорів
лідерів і саме у цьому плані ми будемо
співпрацювати з нашими партнерами в
регіонах і звичайно сьогодні маючи
можливість я хочу залучити до нашої
розмови одного з ключових наших
партнерів це корпорація Intel і
запросити до слова
нашого одного з нашого партнерів це
Томаш Ходаковський який є освітнім
менеджером а проекту і не вийшло
томассоту
is yours please і aval
Today on
Theme місто Моршина ковзки
Amway and friental and
you a few information
Шановні колеги тому що заразковський наш
партнер Він представляє Intel
Corporation І сьогодні він разом
Василевської та її менеджером проекту
скаже декілька слів про проект який
впроваджуються в Україні
ви розумієте що перелік професій які
будуть майбутніми навіть до 2025 року
він значно збільшується і сьогодні до
переліку професій є вимоги відповідно
найбільш затребовими навичками до 25-го
року стануть аналітичне мислення та
інновації активне навчання та стратегія
навчання комплексне вирішення проблем
критичне мислення та аналіз креативність
оригінальність та ініціатива лідерство
та соціальний вплив технологію
використання моніторингу та керування
технологією проектування та
програмування стійкість стресостійкість
і гнучкість міркування і розв'язування
проблем та ідейність
програмністю
Rain Wonder world-технолог
для того щоб підтримати нові професії
вироблення відповідних навичок у для
майбутніх професій корпорація Intel
розробило проект skillso іnnovation який
передбачає підвищення стійкості освіти
освітніх систем перетворивши роль
технологій також використання технологій
для того щоб прискорити тобто сприяти
розвитку мислення та розвитку навичок
використання технологій для того щоб
застосовувати концепції
навчальних програм які пропонуються в
закладах освіти та прив'язувати їх до
вирішення реальних проблем які існують у
кожній професії
Шановні колеги нашого наш проект наша
програма це не лише підготовка вчителів
до використання нових технологій але і
відповідний зміст який мають володіти
вчителі в процесі навчання за програмою
які цей проект є корисний для багатьох
предметів для школи різного рівня Я вже
десь деталізую Шановні колеги для
початкової школи ви бачите на екрані для
Stem які в мене десь для середньої школи
і для старшої школи Next
проект пропонує стат Пакс в нашому
розумінні це розробки занять штат факт
використовується як ключове слово у всіх
країнах тому ми його даємо без перекладу
Шановні колеги ми розуміємо що склад пак
- це розробки занять Отже проект шкіл
своїм новорічним пропонує розробки
занять та Пакс які включають посібник
для вчителя в якому розписано як мета
огляд занять путівники діяльності поради
щодо усунення несправності які виникають
в процесі технічних питань оцінювання
рубрикатори також включать до достатку
навчальний матеріал тобто навчальна
дошка навчальний матеріал який включає
вступні
вступне пояснення практичні заняття
також кероване навчання теми для
обговорення і відповідно рефлексії і
третя складова - це робочий це
матеріали робочі матеріали для вчителя у
відповідні файли перш за все це робочі
аркуші посібник для заповнення для
роботи
додатки
вихідні файли з сходами і відповідно
набори даних
translated
to Ukrainian language so and File for
you can Start Music
classrooms Heroes of
togethering to be and
ми вже говорили вище що стати палки
перекладаються зараз на українську мову
і їх можна використовувати з різних
навчальних предметів відповідно на
нашому на нашому ресурсі
корпорації і на ресурсі інституту
модернізації змісту освіти будуть
розміщені перекладені старти паки які
стосуються абсолютно Всіх
галузей навчання у загальній середній
освіті і позашкільній освіті відповідно
ви бачите тут наприклад біологія ви
бачите там теми як бути щасливими які
стосуються соціальних дисциплін перед
вами на екрані 3 дні принтер де
розписано повністю як приклад заняття
від мети уроку результатів навчання і
описано зміст далі якщо ви почнете
користуватись ви побачите посилання
гіперпосилання на завдання які вже
підібрані в процесі роботи з цієї теми
на посилання джерел які є корисними
тобто я Особисто я вже від себе додам що
вивчивши все це глибоко я зрозуміла що в
основі
цього проекту і сформованих стартепаклів
глибока глибокий науковий підхід
дедактика що дуже важливо для цифрової
освіти і відповідно
витребані вікові особливості
мероприятие Спасибо большое Я хотела
добавить несколько слов к Наталії томаку
Когда мы разговаривали раньше что на
протяжении лет Интер работает совместно
с программой обучения самими главными
Лидер лидерами и мы сараемся как бы
чтобы внедреть новации новые технологии
И поэтому это программа очень важная
чтобы подготовить новые генерации
директоров чтобы использовали новую
технологию готовые обучающие ресурсы
такие как тренинги для директоровки
учителей чтоб вспомнил Томик развивать
новые Новики кристические мышления и
креативное предоставлять возможно для
адаптации повышения комунікацій і
совместно именно свантека і Microsoft
Там ми работали з інститутом
модернизации чтобы создать
интеллектуальные классные кабинеты и
устойчиво система образования чтобы
максимализировать
результаты обучения использовать
новейшую технологию мы построили две
лаборатории очень красиво Я первый - Это
была в Чернигове Университете где
открытие было пятого и тоже в институте
модернизации Где можно будет
использовать все технологии одновременно
И вполне поэтому я благодарно отдала и
Microsoft поддержке для вашей страны
Спасибо большое
дякую дякую пані яланка Дійсно я вже я
вже ще раз дякую вам і вашим колегам за
те що сьогодні Ісус буде реалізації
змісту освіти отримав таку Прекрасну
лабораторію Я думаю що ця лабораторія ми
спільно з обласними інститутами будемо
на цій базі проводити навчання і
вчителів директорів і разом з тим всі
категорії
педагогів які будуть цього будуть
потребували якщо якщо є можливість
приєднатися до нас
Сергій Пономаренко корпорація
Шановні колеги Вітаю вас
наразі спеціалісти компанії латек за
підтримки компанії Intel та Microsoft
побудували дві інноваційної лабораторії
у Чернігівській політехніці та інституті
модернізації змісту освіти А при цьому
ми розуміємо що процес запровадження
інновації в освіті має бути
безперервним і зараз це важливо як
ніколи
завдання максимум створити цілу мережу
подібних лабораторій в Україні за
підтримки Міністерства освіти та наших
потужних партнерів
звичайно інститут модернізації змісту
освіти в цьому процесі виступає
локомотивом який просуває інновації в
освіті та працює безпосередньо з
директорами шкіл та вчителями
Дякую партнерам та колегам за допомогою
реалізації проекту
Шановні колеги подякуємо пану Олександру
за
той вклад який робите для того щоб наші
педагоги дійсно мали таку матеріальну
базу кому мали використовувати для
навчання вчителів щиро вам дякую
Шановні колеги ми Дякуємо нашим
партнерам за плідну співпрацю ми будемо
продовжувати і спільно з обласними
інститутами будемо реалізовувати
завдання школи управлінських кадрів
дякую дякую
Віталій Іванівна
ми маємо Дякуємо за те що сьогодні ми
можемо транслювати нашу
локацію дійсно на тому обладнанні будемо
ставила компанія зараз ми переходимо до
Слідуючого такого блоку нашого
обговорення і я до основа запрошую наших
колег векторів інститутів післядипломної
освіти вони поділяться досвідом як
на їх території вікних областях
вирішуються ці питання які сьогодні
актуальні Як сьогодні проводяться оці
моделі про які я говорив міністр і
навчання як вони виходять з даної
ситуації тому перше достовая запрошую
Ігоря Івановича смайлина це доктора
педагогічних наук директора комунального
закладу в Житомирській області і сутки
за державним педагогічної освіти
Житомирської обласної ради взяв
організаційні аспекти діяльності
закладів післядипломної політики освіти
в умовах війни прошу вас Ігор Іванович
Дякую
Добрий день шановні колеги ради вітати
вас всіх я дійсно Хочу зупинитися на
певних організаційних аспектах роботи
закладу післядипломної освіти без
статусу закладу вищої освіти які
допомогли нам цей важкий час не просто
виживати а залишатися
тими суб'єктами які не ідуть заподіями а
формують порядок денний насамперед будь
ласка презентацію насамперед Хочу
зупинитися на проблемі статусу наших
закладів це дуже важливо організаційна
проблема яка на жаль поки що не вирішена
оскільки з лютого місяця в профільному
комітеті Верховної Ради знаходиться
проект закону Про освіту дорослих які ще
поки не прийнятий але питання стосовно
нашого статусу організаційної структури
багатьох інших питань залишається
відкритим будь ласка далі тому
ще в минулому році ми пройшли перші
серед колег шлях отримання
ліцензії на здійснення освітньої
діяльності вже за новими правилами саме
на нашому прикладі формувався той
сегмент є дебо е-е який підлаштований
тепер під закладу освіти дорослих тому
що попередньо за те що стосувалося
все те що стосувалося підвищення
кваліфікації воно в основному йшло
форматі структур закладів вищої освіти
тим досвідом яким ми набули ми щиро
ділилися з колегами з тими хто приїжджав
до нас з цими з тими виходили на
онлайн-зв'язок якщо також в когось
будуть якісь питання з цього приводу
будь ласка звертайтеся тому що ми
пройшли мушу сказати серйозний мінне
поле На цьому шляху для того щоб ви не
повторювали ті помилки і ті невірні
кроки то ми готові вам підказати і
допомогти крім того згадаємо початок
минулого навчального року коли по суті
всю територію України Обі залишити від
деяких наших недоброчесних конкурентів
які наголошували на тому що заклади
післядипломної освіти на легітимні були
ніби немає ліцензію скільки це на
висвітло на сайті Novo за нашим
проханням Я дякую працівникам
Міністерства освіти і науки України
нарешті на сторінці ліцензійний реєстр
суб'єктів освітньої діяльності у сфері
післядипломної освіти самому носу тепер
закладено той перелік безстрокових
паперових ліцензій які на відміну від
сучасних електронних існують і тепер ці
питання практично зняті крім того щоб не
виникало питання стосовно штату
структури бо оскільки відсутність коштів
війна і багато інших ну був період
ковіду багато інших є моментів коли
деякі керманичі намагаються за рахунок
заходів післядиплом на освіту вирішувати
певні Фінансові проблеми в регіонах ми
прийшли ще наступний етап будь ласка
наступне слайд
Ми отримали
сертифікат на яким підтверджено якість
освітніх послуг у сфері післядипломної
освіти міжнародне сертифікат за Ісусом
за
9001-2015 наявність електронної ліцензії
безстрокової ліцензії і такого
сертифікату тепер дає можливість
абсолютно аргументовано відповідати на
питання з приводу структури штату якості
наданих послуг і багатьох інших питань
далі будь ласка
друге організаційна аспект на яку ми
хотіли би наголосити це те що стосується
співпраці з військово-цивільними
адміністраціями і з
нашими департаментами освіти і науки
така співпраця плюс
вирішення цих організаційних питань
наприклад дали нам можливість в цьому
році в умовах абсолютно свободного
вибору педагогам
відпрацювати майже з 12 тисяч ми
педагогічних працівників причому це
робота відбувалася навіть форматі коли
люди були на блокпостах коли в
староберонні були Практично на
потенційному нулі на північному кордоні
з Білорусією і ця робота здійснювалася
досить пристойно далі будь ласка але ми
по суті була і Фронтова область оскільки
нашої території здійснювалися бойові дії
місто Житомир також було під ракетним
обстрілом під бомбардуваннями Я хочу
сказати що мені на один день не зупиняли
роботу навіть в неї гарячіший час
сервера нашу працювали і викладачі з
безпечних міст продовжували синхроні не
вас синхроні в синхромі впродовжували
роботу з педагогами так от у нас виникла
це як правило в кожній області виникали
ці питання пов'язані з тим що в багатьох
сім'ях гинули різні пропадали безвісно
виникало маса інших питань І отут
потрібно була допомога обласній Владі і
спільно з департаментом освіти і науки і
військово-цивільного адміністрацію ми
створили інформаційну консультаційну
інтернет-платформу в межах якої наших
психологи фахівці нашого закладу плюс ті
хто долучався до цієї роботи і в онлайні
і вживу працювали сім'ями мамами дітьми
які постраждали від насильства тобто і в
основному які сюди до нас пересувалися з
Київщини сім'ями де хтось загинув що
пропав безвісти це дуже серйозна дуже
відповіда соціальна робота яку Спочатку
ми починали робити на ентузіазмі потім
отаким чином організаційно оформили і
сьогодні такий формат роботи де є певні
результати І ми маємо вдячні відгуки від
тих людей яким вдалося нам допомогти
далі будь ласка
також налагоджена була був ще один
аспект роботи з органами ДСНС і
національної поліції в плані безпеки ми
говоримо сьогодні про класи безпеки ми
говоримо сьогодні про мінну безпеку що
для нашої області досить актуально
особливо в північних районах там де
Лісова місцевість От і по суті ця
співпраця почалася спонтанно потім
організаційно оформилася буквально
завтра у нас буде проходити також великі
захід де працівники ДСНС будуть
працювати з керівниками педагогами
області протягом цілого дня до форматі
різних тренінгів далі будь ласка для
того щоб робота була ефективною
зрозуміло що в Нових умовах потрібно
було налагоджувати нові комунікаційні
зв'язки насамперед формат викладач перед
веб-камерою він уже трошки приївся тому
власне ми силами ми організували і
забезпечили роботу кількох по суті
відос-студії це така студія зараз і
знаходжуся але велика студія До речі де
на карті України логотипи всіх закладів
післядипломної освіти України це
своєрідна така карта закладів
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
України вона у нас уже функціонувала
коли ми проводили
всеукраїнський міжнародні наукові
конференції крім того контакт з
педагогами які знаходяться із зброєю
нам чергування на блокпості виконують
якесь завдання але оце спілкування
професійне спілкування воно досить
потрібне я сам був здивований тому що
Думаю що під час війни все те що
стосується
педагогічної діяльності освіти воно десь
відійде на якийсь другий план для людей
для педагогів це дуже важливо і тому
шляхом різних підходів Оскільки ми
випробували всі програмні застосунки всі
месенджери ми зупинилися на двох
основних - це сигнал на основі якого в
основному спілкуємося з тими хто має
відношення до збройних сил групи Вайбері
У нас дуже активна Facebook сторінка з
месенджером і відповідним чином
контактне з педагогами з відповідними
інституціями які працюють з педагогами
закладами освіти у нас постійне і
безперервно навіть будь ласка
заняття з практичними медицини які ми
почали проводити за кілька років до
цього активного ввторення задер-
завдячуючи що Віру борисівні рогові яка
познайомила нас з колишнім атошниками
хлопця з громадської організації Легіон
і таке відділення було створено і також
в нас області і домедичка і тактична
медицина у нас проходили досить активно
результативність цієї роботи - це те що
викладач тактичної медицини ви бачите на
фото майор Валерій Воробйов зараз
знаходиться на нулі на південному
напрямку а поряд з ним Наш вчитель
однієї шкіл Житомирщини який проходив в
нього навчальний який тепер під час
війни працює на посаді парамедика
бригада спеціального призначення
матеріали
занять викладені нами на з першого дня
бойових дій були викладені у нас на
порталі у нас на сайт портал
Інститутській для того щоб всі ті кому
було ці питання пов'язані з до медичної
тактичною медицини вони дуже актуальні і
досі відповідно нам чином вони також
дозволяє можливість багатьом людям
знайти відповіді на ті питання які перед
ними ставали далі будь ласочка
ми вважали з першого дня дуже важливою
морально-психологічну підтримку та
інформаційний спротиву особливо вперше
найважчі місяці коли ну наприклад уже
саме центр Житомира має щоб був
порожніми знаходимося в самому центрі на
пішоходці коли ми як адміністрація
проходила на роботу то просто було якось
абсолютно незвично
шляхом
підбору відповідного матеріалу Я також
своїх друзів француза з Ліона фотографа
і Доктора історичних ну станеться
подільську художників та аркатуристів
також запросив залучив до цієї роботи і
на наших Facebook сторінках особистих і
на Інститутській відповідним чином
практично був такий період що майже
щодня видавалися якісь такі іронічно але
енергетично заряджувальні матеріали які
давали можливість уже трошки зироню і
гумором дивитися на ті страшні речі
події які виникали в нашому житті далі
будь ласка
у нас з'явилися підщеплення крім того що
ми як всі допомагаємо військовому нашу
десантна штурмова У нас є наші
прикордонники у нас з'явився під Шеф не
підрозділ Коли наш працівник став
заступником начальника штабу окремого
батальйону бригада спецпризначення імені
Івана Богуна
причому вперше в боях хлопці себе якось
так назвали укусом згадайте двох героїв
мультяшного серіалу Льодовиковий період
коли їх дії були непередбачувані Отакі
непередбачувані для ворога дій були і у
наших хлопців тому цих з перших днів
також морально підтримали ми робили
імпострів про злихопосумів які на
південному напрямку завдавали школу
гороху але крім моральної підтримки далі
будь ласка Ми за допомогою наших
закордонних партнерів від друзів і дуже
серйозно матеріально підтримує цей
підрозділ ми перекинули їм туди всюдихід
жив для того щоб можна було перевозити
міномети відповідні ми перекинули вже
цілу партію коптер спочатку просто
перекидали ті які з яких можна було
дивитися потім перекидали фізики як
можна було кидати а це останні ви бачите
на фото пластику це вже коптер з
тепловізійною оптикою коли ворога можна
побачити І серед листя далі крім цього
за цей час це невелика частина того чим
ми забезпечували наших підшипних
починаючи з тактичних рукавичок окулярів
а далі пішли лазерне дальноміри приціли
тепловізори американські аптечки
найсучасніші найсучасніша комп'ютерна
техніка для того щоб можна було
працювати з відео працювати з
аерофотознімками для того щоб чітко
бачити де ворог і відповідним чином що з
цим ворогом потрібно робити з самого
останнього Зараз ми чекаємо для наших
хлопців нову передачу яку перекидаємо їм
туди на ноль це
тактичні навушники і радіоста школі ну а
буквально кілька днів назад наші дівчата
з інституту перекинули до величезний
подарунок До Спаса мед і до меду я казав
замкомбата хлопці раділи як діти тому
крім основної роботи яка у нас не
зупинялася такими видами діяльності ми
на жаль не можемо допомагати як Багато
наших колег які є гуртожитки для
розміщення
переселенців але робимо те що можемо для
того щоб активно брати участь в
наближення нашої Перемоги які ніхто не
сумнівається Дякую за увагу і слава
Україні
героям слава Дякую Ігорю івановичу
Шановні колеги я розумію що всі ми
хочемо дуже багато поділитися своїм
досвідом але давайте будемо
дотримуватися регламенту тому що у нас
кожного є свій час і надалі той час який
вам виділено будь ласка дотримуватися
слідуючи про особливості дистанційного
підвищення кваліфікації педагогічних
працівників
з нами поділиться Віктор Володимирович
Савченко це доктор наук ректор
Дніпровської академії неперервної освіти
Віктор Іванович Віктор Володимирович
прошу вас Доброго дня
радий всіх бачити Шановні колеги
діяльність колективу Дніпровської
академії післядипломної освіти За
останні півроку була направлена на
подальший розвиток закладу як сучасного
закладу вищої освіти який здійснює в
тому числі і методичний супровід і
забезпечення системи післядипломної
педагогічної освіти працівників регіону
підвищення кваліфікації керівних кадрів
і педагогічних працівників освіти а
також проводить на базі навчальних
закладів теоретичні та прикладні
дослідження в галузі освіти сприяє
упровадженню їх подальшу практику роботи
дошкільних загальноосвітніх та
позашкільних закладів освіти відповідно
до річного плану академії в період з 28
лютого
організована дистанційне навчання для 10
з половиною тисяч працівників закладів
освіти Дніпропетровщини за допомогою
платформ Google
з метою реалізації державної політики в
сфері реформування загальної середньої
освіти нова українська школа З понеділка
19 серпня Ми розпочали організоване
навчання за програмами підвищення
кваліфікації вчителів 5-6 класів по
реформі нової української школи
впровадження державного стандарту
базової середньої освіти для 2600
педагогів області з метою дослідження
актуальних проблем в освітній галузі
працівникам академії неперервної освіти
було проведено та організовано третю
заочну між кузівську науково-практичну
конференцію за тематикою соціально
гуманітарний підхід до вирішення
актуальних проблем сучасного світу який
взяли участь
з'являється знову педагогічних та
педагогічних працівників другу
всеукраїнську науково-практичну
конференцію освітня робототехніка який
взяли участь 58 осіб регіональної
науково-практичний семінар іноваційний
розвиток сучасної освіти від теорії до
практики один з пріоритетних
модернізації освіти складової частини
державної політики з підвищення рівня
конкурентаспроможності національної
економіки та розвитку людського капіталу
одним з основних факторів інноваційної
діяльності сфері освіти що відповідає
запитам економіки та окремим суспільства
є посилення ролі stem-освіти
дніпропетровщина бере активну участь в
даному напрямку розвитку освіти
співробітниками академії проводилися
наступні заходи в рамках всеукраїнського
фестивалю стен весна та стем тижня
20-22 онлайн на платформі Google Meet
було проведено марафон міст ідей в якому
взяли участь педагоги та з 69
експериментальних закладів області в
червні було проведено нараду для
керівників експериментальних тем
закладів їх заступників та членів
творчих груп під час заходу були
розглянуті питання формування планів
науково-дослідної роботи
експериментальних закладів що працюють
за темою розроблення та впровадження
наукового навчально-методичного
забезпечення stem-освіти в умовах
реформування освітньої галузі на цей
навчальний рік українська суспільство
сьогодні переживає важливий і складний
час створення нової української школи в
контексті сучасного розвитку освіти
України освітня реформи виводить на
новий організаційний та концептуальний
рівень заклади загальної середньої
освіти щодо втілення так практичної
реалізації стратегії сучасного
суспільного розвитку та впровадження
державного стандарту базової середньої
освіти з метою реалізації нового змісту
навчання на рівні базової середньої
освіти
відповідні травня 22-го року проведена
онлайн-конференції для педагогічних
працівників які забезпечують реалізацію
нового державного стандарту базової
середньої освіти
відповідно до професійного стандарту за
професіями вчитель початкових класів
закладу загальної середньої освіти
вчитель закладу загальної середньої
освіти вчитель з початкової освіти
з дипломом молодшого спеціаліста основна
мета професійної діяльності вчителя
полягає в організації навчання та
виховання учнів під час здобуття ними
повної загальної середньої освіти шляхом
формування в них ключових
компетентностей та світогляду на основі
загальнолюдських та національних
цінностей процеси навчання виховання та
розвитку учнів є наскрізним їх
цілісність полягає і забезпечується
наявність учителя загальних та
професійних компетентностей необхідними
для виконання всіх трудових функцій
співробітниками академії проведена низку
заходів підвищення професійних
компетентностей працівників закладів
освіти зокрема в червні ми провели
підсумкову зустріч щодо результатів
науково-методичного супроводу
експериментального провадження
варіативного предмету повага любов секс
для
співробітної для здобувачів освіти які
отримують повну загальну середню освіту
на базі закладів професійної та
професійно-технічної освіти
з квітня по червень в академії було
проведено за підтримки Департаменту
освіти і науки обласної адміністрації
соціально-освітній проект з Україною в
серці в якому взяли участь 560
здобувачів фахової передвищої освіти та
61 педагогічний працівник
Також маю сказати що на сайті
Дніпровської академії на освіту
оприлюднення каталог кращих педагогічних
практик
і цей каталог призначений для
педагогічних працівників та керівників
закладів освіти області а також
консультантів в центрі професійного
розвитку педагогічних працівників під
час воєнних дій гуртожитки академії
стали прихистком для чотирьох сотень
внутрішньо переміщених осіб серед які є
і найвразливіша категорія - це діти які
потребують особливої уваги маю сказати
що в минуле понеділок у нас з візитом
перебувала
віце-прем'єр-міністр пані варищук яка
високо оцінила нашу роботу стосовно
допомоги
внутрішнього перемищеними особам і
зокрема можна сказати що ми в академії
забезпечуємо
роботу і
супровід для дітей віком від трьох років
до 16 в тому числі різноманітними нашими
заходами і психологічної підтримки і
іншими заходами які ми організуємо з
різними громадськими організаціями та
комунальними закладами області
зокрема і
різноманітний матеріал і конструктори
Lego тощо
Шановні колеги незважаючи на складни
умови та події що зараз відбуваються в
Україні дуже важливо зосередити нашу
увагу на реформуванні та розвитку освіти
тому що освіта це запорука світлого
майбутнього для України та її молодого
покоління перш за все А також освіта
відіграє важливу роль у сприянні
верховенства права та розбудові культури
для майбутніх поколінь Дніпровська
академія неперервної освіти і надалі
буде працювати на благо України
продовжуючи здійснювати педагогічний та
психологічний супровід професійного
розвитку педагогічних працівників
Дніпропетровської області Дякую за увагу
Дякую Вікторія володимировичу і до слова
запрошую Романа Миколайовича суб'яка
котра до педагогічних наук ректора
івано-франківського обласного інституту
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
Роман Миколайович поділиться з нами як в
області
проходить Ось на дистанційна форма
навчання в системі діяльності
закладів освіти як прошу вас Дякую
реально що Вітаю колеги Слава Україні
на сьогодні дуже складно В умовах
воєнного стану давати якісь рекомендації
чи ділитися досвідом організації
підвищення кваліфікації
який сформований в першу чергу
відповідно до безпекової ситуації що для
нас всіх важливо На мою думку це
мобільність та наявність дієвих
інструментів для швидкої реакції на
зміни та виклики в організації у формах
та змісті підвищення кваліфікації
останні три роки ми вибудовуємо систему
яка дає нам можливості реагувати на
форс-мажори і швидко перебудовувати це
комплексна система управління процесом
проведення курсів підвищення
кваліфікації як елемент програмного
комплексу управління підприємством
візового сервіс
це великий багатофункціональний продукт
який автоматизує Весь процес організації
підвищення кваліфікації від початку
завершення на презентацію його звичайно
треба багато часу тому я в межах своїх 5
хвилин спробували тільки акцентувати
базові компоненти цього продукту
на цій моделі ви бачите чотири базові
компоненти це внутрішнє управління
процесом організації курсів це
інститутське середовище яке ви буде вони
на за функціоналом та розподілено за
рівнями доступу до усіх для усіх
працівників які беруть участь у
організації курсів вона синхронізує
організаційний модуль платформу
дистанційного навчання модула також
додаток до для синхронних конференцій
Google Мінськ онлайн платформа
підвищення кваліфікації педагогічних
працівників це цифровий функціонал для
керівників закладів освіти та
педагогічних працівників які дає
можливість персональної реєстрації на
курси з можливістю вибору змісту форм і
терміни навчання
сертифікація слухачів генерується
персональні електронні генерує
персональні електронні сертифікати
слухачів та завантаження в кабінеті
закладів освіти а також у відкритий
архів виданих сертифікатів для перевірки
їх автентичності на сайті нашого
інституту Ну і була розроблена білінгова
система
автоматизована система обліку надання
надання послуг вона розроблялася для
організації та проведення курсів за
кошти державної субвенції дозволяє нам
автоматично кабінетах розпорядників
коштів генерувати угоди на проведення
курсів фактично Акти виконаних робіт
аналіз проплати відповідно до актів і
які звичайно кінцеві акти звірки між
суб'єктами угоди
трішки ширше зупинимося на двох
функціонах функціональних модулях на
внутрішній інститутському який дає
можливості для отримання планового
цифрового замовлення Ми вже його
проводимо у вересні для підготовки
бюджетного запиту на наступний
фінансовий рік формування кількості
навчальних груп зрозуміло за категоріями
генерування плану курсів з функціями
вибору форм термінів із змісту навчання
для педагогічних працівників формування
розкладу занять для групи викладачів по
викладачах є важливий нюанс програма
виключає повтор одночасного вибору
викладача у кількох групах і тут не
виникає проблем накладок викладачів
генерування навчально-тематичних планів
які пізніше трансформуються в
групові журнали робота з реєстром
слухачів відповідність попереднього
реєстру до фактичного перебування на
навчаннях робота з угодами і актами про
це субвенцією Я вже про це говорив
зовнішній модуль для керівників закладів
освіти і під працівників
орієнтований в основному на більшій мірі
на керівників і вони мають такі
можливості сформувати довідник
педагогічних працівників закладу з
інформацією про проходження курсів
попередні роки форму для реєстрації
педпрацівників за курсами на етапи ви
бачите тут де стрілочки вибір категорії
посади форму підвищення кваліфікації
зміст варіанту який вибирає педагогічний
працівник і дату проходження курсів
керівник може переглянути реєстр та при
потребі внести потрібне отримати
статистичні дані про проходження курсу
своїх працівників і іншу інформацію Ну і
звичайно може переглянути сертифікат або
зробити верифікацію його через qr-код
кілька слів про форми підвищення
кваліфікації
наші основні програми розраховані на
проходження слухачем 150 годинного курсу
за 5 років
очищурічно ми пропонуємо 31 курс для
кожної категорії до слова Слухач може
вибирати весь курс може вибирати його
частину
практикуємо різні форми очного 24
аудиторних + 6 самостійно дистанційно 24
синхронно плюс-6 самостійно для окремих
категорій працівників педагогічних
працівників та наприклад такі для
керівників закладів освіти які
потребують між особистісної комунікації
або вчителів можете потрібна ґрунтовна
тренінгова робота може бути змішана
форма навчання 8 можна наприклад 16
дистанційно 6-6 самостійно тут
верифікація тут вибір може бути різний
зрештою історично історичний Континент у
25 тисяч плюс змушує нас запроваджувати
різноманіття у формах підвищення
кваліфікації але це не складає значною
проблемою організації курсів оскільки
програмний комплекс дозволяє короткий
термін змінити форму навчання адже
потребує змін тільки графіку курсів і
розкладу тому що тривалість курсів різна
до прикладу цей рік ми починали очень На
початку березня ми три дні за три дні
віддалено від робочих місць провели
систему дистанційно за перші півріччя в
повній мірі виклали план і витрат не
втратили жодної групи До речі спад
контингенту у нас був зовсім невеликий
навіть в зв'язку з тим що люди виїжджали
менше 10%
.»
який необхідно додати відповідно до
нової які необхідно додати відповідно до
нової освітньої політики або є якісь
інші обставини щодо необхідності змісту
до прикладу Ми хочемо для окремих
категорій слухачів з вересня ввести
безпека і модуль цивільний захист плюс
змінна безпека плюс перша медична
допомога або вести навчальну програму по
демократичному урядуванню за проектом
дісайд нам тільки слід зробити певні
зміни переліку навчальних модулів Ну і
звичайно знайти фахівців підготувати
відповідний контент це система проста
надійна зручна якщо когось зацікавить ми
готові поділитися інформацією про те як
ми працюємо ширше значення найголовніше
що я хочу сказати Сьогодні
я хочу звернутися до наших колег які
зараз страждають на тимчасово окупованих
територіях покинули свої домівки та
місце праці перебувають під постійними
ракетними обстрілами Сокальського
окупанта ми пишаємося вами
за вашу відданість Україні за відданість
нашій справі готові завжди підставити
плече допомоги тримаємо стрій віримо в
ЗСУ працюємо на перемогу переможемо
Дякую за увагу
Дякую вам Романа Миколайовичу переходимо
до Слідуючого нашого питання
Шановні колеги ми сьогодні
Запрошуємо запросили ректорів
педагогічних вузів до нашої такої
локації Я думаю що тільки це початок
надалі десь ми всі нараду Я вже
попередньо говорив будемо спільну
проводити із
нашими педагогічними навчальними
закладами не тільки із
медуніверситетами але із педагогічними
колесами тому що підготовка початкових
класів дуже сьогодні питання актуальне і
надалі Я думаю 16 співпраця а сьогодні
мені хочеться запросити до слова Юрія
Дмитровича Бойчука це доктора
педагогічних наук професора та
некореспондента ректора Харківського
національного педагогічного університету
імені Григорія Сковороди чому саме Юрія
Дмитровича тому що ми хочемо почути як
сьогодні Харків не знаю чи те що частина
приміщення
ідуть військові дії як в таких умовах
цей навчальний заклад все ж таки
незважаючи на все і значить 1 вересня
продовжить навчання прошу вас
Вітаю шановний Юрій іваничу Вітаю Дорогі
колеги з конференцією з початком нового
навчального року і дуже дякую за надану
можливість брати участь у такій в такому
поважному заході І хочу сказати що
мабуть вперше за багато років нашої
Незалежності
Міністерство освіти і науки нашої
держави приділяє велику увагу саме до
педагогічних університетів весь час мова
йшла про школу але як можна
забезпечувати в освітній процес у школі
не маючи підготовленого вчителя І от
вперше в минулому році на форумі який
відбувся в місті Харкові за
безпосередньої участі і допомозі в
організації цього формулу в нашому
університетам Сергій Миколайович сказав
такі важливі слова мабуть такий девіз
під яким має жити освіта педагогічна
освіта в нашій країні що еліта формує
еліту і сьогоднішня локація вона
присвячена саме підготовці
освітянської еліти підготовців вчителів
і я хочу сказати що дійсно останні роки
від
чиновників від освіти звучали слова про
те що епічні університети це пережитки
радянського минулого вони не потрібні
концепції педагогічної освіти було
записано що вчителя може готувати
будь-який заклад вищої освіти навіть
перелічені класичні технічні аграрні всі
хто зможе акредитувати освітню програму
з 014 середнього освіти але це не так і
ще В 1925 році коли вперше з'явилися
педагогічні інститути потім університети
то вони мали уже функцію ідеологічних
інституцій в державі які формують
Громадяни мають підготувати вчителів
місія яких формувати громадян своєї
країни Я хочу сказати що дійсно от в
нашому університеті це унікальне
створене
освітньо-виховне культурно-духовне
середовище яке дозволяє формувати
сучасного вчителя як майстерність якого
професіоналізм не тільки в переліку тих
програмних компетентностей які він має
засвоїти а перш за все в особливі
громадянській позиції і виконав місії
нашого університету написано формування
патріота громадянина професіонала ця
місія в нас Давно ми її
виконуємо і це є нашим основним
дороговказом І
дійсно Наш університет серед 15 медичних
університетів України він посідає ну в
рейтингу які там зараз проводяться п'яте
місце і ми пишаємося тим що є одним із
провідних закладів вищої педагогічної
освіти в нашому Харківському регіоні ну
поряд і звичайно з нашою
гуманітарно-педичною академією ми
виконуємо місію підготовки вчителя ми
зараз маємо
контингент який складається з 5000
студентів сьогодні здійснюємо підготовку
здобувачів вищої освіти вищої
педагогічної освіти на трьох рівнях
бакалавському магістерському і
освітньо-науковому рівні рівні доктора
філософії для наших абітурієнтів ми
пропонуємо 110 освітніх програм 59
бакалавратів 41 програму магістратурі і
спеціальностей наші здобувачі доктора
філософії можуть отримати в аспірантурі
і маємо також
докторантуру підготовка докторів наук
Наукова підготовка ведеться також за
десятьма спеціальностями хочу сказати що
маємо належну матеріально-технічну базу
маємо потужний
кадровий потенціал на сьогоднішній день
У нашому університеті працює 120
докторів наук із них левова доля
звичайно належить докторам педагогічних
наук ми можемо майже 400 кандидатів наук
доцентів які забезпечують освітні
науковий процес в нашому університеті
ведемо підготовку на 10 факультетах
маємо в складі інститут післядипломної
педагогічної освіти і менеджменту
забезпечуємо перепідготовку вчителів і
до війни у нас дві з половиною тисячі
щорічно приходили вчителів і ми надавали
якісні послуги з перепідготовки І
сьогодні ми за всіма акредитованими
освітніми програмами це робимо і
пропонуємо 86 спецкурсів додатково маємо
розгалужено спортивну інфраструктуру
у нас серед наших випускників уславлення
чемпіони світові чемпіони які колись
приносили славу і ті великі країні
колишній і Україні звичайно в нашому
місту Харкову і нашому університеті хочу
сказати що коли почалася війна Звичайно
Це був надзвичайний виклик для нашого
університету і хочу сказати що
скородинівська родина вона
змобілізувалася дуже стислі терміни і Ми
зрозуміли що звичайно наша участь - це
освітянський науковий фронт який має
наближати нашу країну до перемоги і з
першого дня і по сьогоднішній день ми ні
на хвилину не зупинили освітній процес
за винятком тих вимушених канікул які
були в усій Україні Ми розпочали
заняття звичайно в режимі онлайн з 1
квітня і повністю виконали навчальні
плани
заняття проводилися в дистанційному
режимі хочу сказати що технології
дистанційного навчання вони були у нас
відпрацьовані Ну звичайно за ті періоди
карантинів які ми пережили всі разом з
вами але великим
досягненням нашого університету було те
інформацію 25 років тому назад і ще в
нашому університеті було створено
інститут інформатизації освіти якраз
були розроблені дуже багато методик
змішаного навчання
електронного навчання і це звичайно нам
дало змогу легко і безболісно перейти на
віддалене навчання і звичайно коли
почалася війна то це було для нас
скажімо значним таким моментом який
дозволив нам абсолютно в такому штабному
можна сказати І от ми всі
українські громаді всі спільноті
доводили про те що ми на високому рівні
забезпечуємо освітній процес от в
складних умовах війни проводимо виховну
роботу проводимо наукові заходи ми
тільки за період війни провели 19 дуже
солідних науково-практичних конференцій
Всеукраїнських міжнародних провели
велику кількість відкрити конвекцій
вебінарів
мабуть кількість заходів наукових і
освітніх виховних у нас мабуть була
менша коли ми працювали в звичайному
офлайн режимі Я хочу низько вклонитися
своїм викладачам своїм студентам за те
що вони змогли так з організуватися у
такий складний для нашої держави періоду
ми використовуємо для дистанційного
навчання платформу Moodle завдяки
допомозі Харківської
інтернет-компанії ми єпа ми її перевели
у хмарне середовище убезпечили від
можливих
руйнацій А руйнації ви знаєте Ну якщо
говорити про Харків то з 24 закладів
вищої освіти державної форми власності
21 зазнав руйнацій 6 серпня один із семи
корпусів нашого університету було вщент
знищено ударом ракети Іскандер і коли
приїхав до нас в університет у нас
Сергій Миколайович карлик був 13 серпня
І от коли був сенатор штату Небраска він
зразу сказав Я знаю чого сюди втрапила
ця ракета бо це ідеологічний центр тут
готують вчителя вчителя який формує
патріотичне налаштування у ваших
громадян
США має намір ви знаєте відновлювати
Харків після війни він сказав титульному
списку відновлювальних робіт ми вашу
університет будемо намагатися ставити в
перші ряди Дуже дякую за таке розуміння
за таке ставлення до педагогічної освіти
до педагогічних університетів що як
ніколи сьогодні усвідомлюють
місія вчителя - це
підготовка саме
непереможного бійця освітянського фронту
який здатний виховувати у
своїх вихованців
справжній громадян країни які
намірні обороняти свою землю родину
близьких людей
виховувати молодь до безпечного життя до
життя у мирі Мирного співіснування
рухатися
до прогресивного розвитку долати життєві
перешкоди ми
зараз навчальний рік розпочали трошечки
раніше він в нас розпочався 15 серпня
старші курси бакалавраті і магістратурі
з 15 серпня ми розпочнемо навчальний
процес на першому курсі бакалавраті і 1
жовтня В магістратурі ну мабуть
зрозуміло чого ми так зробили бо
Харків знаходиться в Епіцентрі бойових
подій з першого дня війни і по
сьогоднішній день з червня місяця
щоденно без будь-якого
будь-якої перерви щоночі ворог наносить
ракетні удари якщо їх раніше було 2-3 то
ось останні три дні декілька разів по
10-12 ракет ми вже пережили із кандери
ми знаємо що таке S300 ми знаємо що таке
ракета калібр ми знаємо що таке ракета
кінжал кожної ночі місто здригається але
ми живемо працюємо сьогодні маємо
1600 заяв від дорієнтів
600 абітурієнтам ми присвоїли код 109 -
це квота 2 це діти з особливими
небезпечних регіонів Я переконаний що
вони будуть нашими студентами Ми зробимо
вдалий набір маємо уже програму розвитку
університету післявоєнний період хочу
подякувати кардіовському університету є
така президентська програма між урядова
з великою британією 10 провідних
закладів вищої освіти Великої Британії
самостійно обрали собі один університет
в Україні і надають йому допомогу
фінансову матеріальну
забезпечує академічну мобільність це
кардіовський університет в південному
уельсі Вони мають великі наміри щодо
фінансової підтримки нашого університету
то звичайно Сергій Миколайович після
візиту сказав що після війни будемо
відбудовувати нічого страшного немає все
буде
так як було раніше і набагато краще ніж
було у нас є дуже поважна харків'янка
руфи Бекетова Олена Федорівна - це Онука
Великого архітектора Харківського
Олексія Миколайовича Бекетова вона також
запропонувала допомогу
фінансову то я сподіваюся що університет
відновиться буде працювати працює зараз
я вірю
нашу Вчительську місію вона справді
зробить нашу Україну великою сильною
європейською державою все буде Україна
Слава збройним силам України слава
українському народові Слава Україні
Дякую за увагу
Дякую вам Юрій дмитровичу
від імені наших цій педагогічній
спільноти дійсно подякувати вам вашому
колективу і всім освітянам дійсно тих
регіонів які сьогодні потерпають від
нальота ворожої авіації від тих
ракетиків кожен день падають на ваші
навчальні заклади і на ваші оселі за
вашу мужність за вашу стійкість і ви
знаєте що ми завжди з вами і з вами Вся
Україна Дякуємо вам дякуємо дякуємо
служимо у світі України
переходимо до Слідуючого питання Я вже в
своєму коротенькому виступу говорив що у
нас вже в освіті появилися нові такі
Терміни це освітній Хабі Це ці такі
центри де
всі переселенцям і в Україні і в Європі
надають такі різні послуги і по цьому
питанню доповість нам Станіслав Ігорович
доктор філософії помічник нашого
директора і надаємо слово будь ласка
Доброго дня колеги презентую вам
презентую вам мережу українських
освітніх хабіб абсолютно вірно було
зазначено сьогодні і міністром Сергієм
шкарлутом Юрій Іванович і керівництво
інституту модернізації звісно освіти
говорила про те що дійсно у перші дні
війни була створена мережа українських
освітніх Ви можете бачити вона створена
за підтримки Міністерства освіти і науки
України інституту модернізації змісту
освіти асоціації інноваційної та
цифрової освіти та освітнього хабу міста
Києва наступний слайд будь ласка
Як ви знаєте в перші дні війни ми всі
стали свідками драматичних подій І
багато хто змушений був переміститися
або в інші регіони України або взагалі в
інші країни за оцінками управління
верховного комісара ООН у справах
біженців цифри є вражаючими Це більше
ніж 6,5 мільйонів українців виїхало за
кордон а понад 8 мільйонів стало
внутрішнього переселенцями Як ви
пам'ятаєте сьогодні із цифр які
озвучував міністр це понад 600 тисяч
учнів які зараз знаходяться за кордоном
і близько 80 тисяч учнів які знаходяться
в Західній Україні більш детальні цифри
Ви можете бачити на зображення Польща є
найбільшим реципієнтом переселенців від
України і опитування показують про те що
ті громадяни які знаходяться зараз за
кордоном поки що ще не планують
повернення але безумовно Ми повинні
створити всі умови для того щоб вони
розуміли що необхідно повертатися в
Україну у нас буде ми послухати слайд
будь ласка
тож яка ключова місія освітніх це перш
за все можливість учням дітям студентам
продовжувати процес навчання сьогодні
говорилося вже про те що є різні форми є
ті хто залишиться безпосередньо
навчатися в своїх місцях досі
переселенців хтось за кордоном але в
осінній хаби передбачають якраз
можливість для всіх для всіх
продовжувати навчатися а й батькам дітей
які в цей час навчаються здобувати нові
професії незалежно від місця перебування
і реалізувати концепцію навчання
протягом життя лайфханглер наступний
слайд будь ласка
тож основними напрямками діяльності
мережі українських освітніх хабів які
створюються як на заході України так і
за кордоном це є забезпечення освітнього
процесу причому планується впровадження
новітніх технологій це Віртуальна
реальність та додана реальність вирішили
вона полягає в тому що ті напрацювання
які були здійснені в освітньому Хабі
міста Києва вони будуть
розповсюджуватися далі на інші регіони
також в Європу зокрема це окуляри
віртуальної реальності які уже мають
програму навчання за ключовими
предметами перш за все це предмети які
входять в систему систему освіти це
фізика яка є в доповній реальності хімія
біологія
додана реальність полягає в тому що
через планшети учні можуть мати бачити
не просто навчальні матеріали а
інтерактивні навчальні матеріали які
роблять такі складні науки для них
цікавими і такими що приваблюють їхню
увагу наступна місія освітній хабіб - це
ви це мов як мовою місцевий так і
англійською поясню чому Тому що якщо
людина приїжджає за кордон для неї дуже
важко інтегруватися місцеве середовище і
є важливим вивченням місцевої мови ми в
процесі спілкування з міжнародними
партнерами визначили що для них є
важливим дві речі з одного боку щоб
логічно інтегрувалися українці в тій
спільноти де Вони переживають Але разом
з тим щоб вони не втрачали зв'язок з
Батьківщиною тому ми пропонуємо як
вивчення української мови онлайн через
відповідні платформи так само
англійською і зараз розвиваються інші
напрямки для того щоб вивчати інші мови
можливо аспект про який сьогодні
говорили Юрій Іванович про це зазначав і
міністр про це говорив це психологічна
та емоційна підтримка Я знаю що наші
колеги партнери інституту модернізації
змісту освіти згодом презентують
платформу психологічної підтримки вона
отримала підтримку від офісу президента
від першої Леді і впевнені що з 1
вересня буде активно впроваджуватися
зокрема в форматі 5 хвилин Коли у
Вчителі можуть швидко приходити в
ресурсний стан швидкий незважаючи на
бомбардування інші стреси і продовжувати
навчання наступний напрямок - це
тренінги Soft Skills які навички ми
знаємо що стресостійкість управління
часом фінансова грамотність стала дуже
актуальними в нашому суспільстві і діти
та їхні батьки зможуть освоювати ці
навички наступний напрямок - це
короткострокові навчальні програми щодо
робітничих та іт-професій з прикладу
освітнього хабу Хмельниччини зазначу що
коли було запропоновано понад 48
робітничих професій дуже активно
переселенці яких було 150 тисяч області
на це відгукувалися найбільше професію
яка була популярною стала Швачка дуже
багато було охочих і вони були
випускниками які одразу отримали роботу
Чому Тому що безумовно жінки дівчата
Інколи хлопці шили все необхідне для
нашої армії форму амуніть чи інші речі
все що могли робити і it спеціальності
теж були досить популярними і ще один
напрямок це інформування тому що до
існуючих освітніх кар'єрних та
комунікаційних можливостей це щодо
профорієнтації перш за все для того щоб
визначити професію яка найбільша людині
підходить І щоб на новому місці вона
знайшла роботу людина така Тобто хтось
із батьків або вже підростаючий студенти
і змогли швидко освоїти цю професію і по
ній отримувати кошти отримувати себе і
організація змістовного дозвілля
особливо це важливо для іноземних країн
де діти мають Зараз більше часу влітку і
вони можуть змістовно проводити дозвілля
не просто бути на вулиці
на завершення для того щоб не
затримувати від нашої конференції про
географію освітніх хабіб зараз освітні
хаби існують в місті Києві це Прототип
який був взятий за основу наступним
хабом активно розвивався хаб
Хмельницький області з березня 2022 року
через нього вже прийшли понад 7 тисяч
переселенців і цифра постійно
збільшується наступні хаби будуть в
Львівській Тернопільській та інших
західних областях більшість з них
запрацює З 1 вересня інші в принципі
восени 2022 року і правильно було
зазначено про мережу міжнародних
освітніх хабіб було презентовано хап у
Варшаві в Польщі у липні за участю
міністра освіти України Департаменту
освіти Польщі і Євгена боженкова
директор інституту модернізації змісту
освіти також працює Hub у Швейцарії в
Женеві на днях відкриється хаб у
лейпцигу в Німеччині і восени це будуть
бути в Будапешті Але разом з тим мережею
на цьому не буде завершено тому що в
Україні планується відкриття до 10 хабіб
а в Європі до 14 хв користуючись нагодою
звертаюся до учасників наших заходів в
тих регіонах де розвивалися хаби ми
побачили дуже цікаву тенденцію коли
незважаючи на
ініціативу області територіальні громади
обласного Департаменту освіти самостійно
створювали хаби це хаби територіальних
громад я звертаю зараз до тих регіонів
які не входять в перелік названий мною і
в принципі в регіонах Центральної
України можливо північно-східної
створювати освітні хаби самостійно
безумовно Міністерство освіти інститут
модернізація змісту освіти надасть всю
необхідну підтримку і по будь-яких
питаннях ви можете безпосередньо
звертатися до інституту модернізації
змісту освіти до Євгена боженкова до
директора до мене ми надамо всю
необхідну методичну організаційну
підтримку для того щоб мережа освітніх
хабіб розшила все і до вашої уваги тут є
веб-сайт на якому можна дізнатися
максимальну кількість деталей дякую вам
Шановні колеги переходимо до чого нашого
блоку таких питань ви знаєте що сьогодні
дуже активно йде робота в підготовці
матеріалів навчальних курсів нової
української школи особливо базової
середньої освіти і довгий час
Міністерство освіти і наші інститут
співпрацює із громадською освітою тому
ми зараз до слова запрошую свою
електричку
громадської спілки історій та
новопечерської школи яка поділиться з
нами розробленими навчальним курсом
базова середня освіта будь ласка
вітання колеги
чутно мене
чудово рада всіх бачити рада бути у
компанії чудових освітяни надзвичайно
щасливо що доки наші Захисники захисниці
тримають передову ми з вами тримаємо
освітній фронт і таким чином виборюємо
наше завтра і шанс на якісне навчання і
реалізація для наших дітей ці котрі
будуть майбутніми освітянами науковцями
підприємцями і політиками
цей рік звичайно особливий Він має дуже
багато викликів але будемо їх долати
разом І власне хочу представити той курс
який допоможе вчителям в роботі з
реформою нова українська школа школа з
її продовженням ну і тут я попрошу
поділитися екраном
організатори У нас є вже права Ви маєте
можливість таку Чудово дякую видно мою
презентацію так
Так отже чому реформа нуш залишається на
часі навіть під час війни
ви знаєте що маленькі непосидючі учні
початкової школи які навчалися вже за
стандартами нуш вони зовсім інші вчителі
які працюють в класах мали змогу це
помітити Ну і власне сама реформа нуш з
реформ незалежної України є найбільш
підтримуваною суспільством рейтинги і
підтримки - це
76%, що для України безпрецедентно але
для нас якось освітян ще дуже важливими
є відгук вчителів батьків та й самих
учнів те що ми чуємо від вчителів що
завдяки нуш вдалося досягти тієї
співпраці Яка вже є традицією в освітніх
супердержавах учні є більш розкуті вони
є більш вільними вони розвивають свою
дослідницьку компетенцію це навчання
заради практики і найголовніше що їм
подобається навчання і це відмічають
вчителі і батьки ну от власне
81% батьків підтримують реформу нуш це
опитування батьків пілотних класів і так
само підтримують її 55% спеціалізованих
закладів і 51% загальноосвітніх шкіл Ну
тут цифра не такі високі але я думаю
пов'язано це з реалізацією І власне
підтримка вчителів впровадженні цієї
реформи є важливою Бо як ти можеш
написати будь-який чудовий план дій але
якщо вчитель не має конкретних
інструментів конкретних знань для
впровадження реформи на практиці то
реформа залишиться на папері А ми собі
цього дозволити не можемо адже
величезна кількість маленьких українців
зараз перебувають на навчанні за
кордоном там де Навчання вже
відбувається в школі за тими стандартами
які пропонує реформа нова українська
школа тому попри війну маємо її
продовжувати Я дуже рада представити
курс який зветься нуш базова середня
освіта це курс зроблений для вже
середньої школи він зроблений нашою
командою разом з міністерством освіти
України і за підтримки фонду дитячого
фонду ООН юнісеф
що є у курсі для вчителів-предметників
ну по-перше це така велика тема новий
зміст освіти для того щоб вчителі знали
в чому цінність реформи нуш які її
індикатори для чого вона взагалі
потрібна далі це про дітей нуш Хто вони
такі які їхні особливості Чому вони інші
Все базуються на дослідженнях і все
науково доведено далі ця Сучасні підходи
в роботі з учнівством і це такий вже
широкий інструментарій практичні
лайфхаки Які вчителі можуть брати і
одразу впроваджувати в своїх класах
окремий блок ми присвятили важливій темі
оцінювання і тут буде і про формувальне
оцінювання і про різницю між ссмент
такими поняттями рубриками оцінювання з
чудовими експертами важливий такий
повний блок Ну і останній такий важливий
розділ - це модуль
різних галузей тобто тут
вчителі-предметники зможуть обрати саме
ту галузь які викладають вони і знайти
практичні інструменти від експертів саме
для себе щоб принести це в свої класи
курс як я сказала розрахований на
вчителів 5-6 класів які цього року
підхоплюють естафету від початкової
школи але насправді багато корисного для
себе знайдуть всі вчителі-предметники
навіть можуть підтримати свої знання
вчителі початкової школи та я загалом
освітянами навіть батькам це може бути
цікавий курс попередні курс який ми
робили в 17-му році Разом з
міністерством освіти на сьогодні є
найпопулярнішим курсом на Європейському
континенті його під ключ пройшло майже
300 тисяч учнів під ключ і це змушує
пишатися українськими вчителями
українським освітянами
розробниками цього курсу є 25 експертів
практиків з усієї України які мають
надзвичайні досягнення в своїх класних
кімнатах і курс об'єднує 22 уроки
він є безкоштовним це
можливість вчителя навчатися протягом
життя і підвищувати свою кваліфікацію
після проходження курсу вчитель отримує
сертифікат на підвищення кваліфікації на
30 годин але звичайно якщо вчитель зможе
успішно подолати тести Дякую за увагу це
буде нова українська школа і попри війну
разом з вами будемо продовжувати цю
успішну реформу дякую
дякую пані Зоя Дякую вашій спілці
освіторіях за ту допомогу за ту працю
яку ви ми спільно з вами робимо для
нової української школи
на все добре До побачення і продовжуючи
дальше
розмову про нову українську школу мені
хочеться запросити до слова але Леоніду
чорнійця директорку Рівненського
обласного інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти політичних груп яка
поділиться нам з досвідом про те як
їхній області йде
підготовка до
реформування нової української школи
будь ласка аналогів до слова Запрошуємо
вас Добрий день шановні колеги
надзвичайно приємно і щиро вдячні за те
що має можливість долучитися почути і
побачити стосовно того як Рівненський
обласний інститут післядипломної
педагогічної освіти працює в умовах
війни Рівненський обласний інститут
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
продовжує роботу з провадження нового
держав стандарту базової середньої
освіти розпочато Згідно з наказом
міністерства освіти і науки України від
2 квітня 21 року за числом 406 одним із
найпріорітетніших напрямків роботи для
інституту стала масштабна підготовка
вчителів саме п'ятих класів до роботи в
умовах реалізації нового державного
стандарту що було зроблено в період з 30
травня по 28 червня 22-го року для
вчителів закладів загальної середньої
освіти які в 22-23 навчальних роках
навчатимуть учнів п'ятих класів
організовано серію вебінарів щодо роботи
в умовах реалізації державного стандарту
базової середньої освіти усього на
навчання було зареєстровано
8275 педагогічних працівників з них
керівників закладах 452
мовно-літературна галузь
2582 іншомовна освіта 1014 математична
845 природничі 743 технологічна 557
інформативна 70 працюють здоров'я
збережувальна 520 і соціальна
громадянська та історична 657 Мистецьке
653 фізична культура 557 чому я говорю
про статистику це говорить про те що
незважаючи Не дивлячись на те що Вчителі
були із-за кордоном і в таких умовах
вони всі пройшли активно долучились і
пройшли навчання до навчання окрім
працівників інституту були долучені
автори модельних програм і підручників
що дуже було цінним для вчителя і в
принципі вчитель якраз і Хотів
зустрітися проговорити визначити період
пріоритетні напрямки саме із авторами
підручників також долучилися вчителі
пілотних шкіл представники управління
державної служби якості освіти
Вінницькій області усі відеозаписи від
вебінарів розміщені у відкритому доступі
на youtube-каналі інституту доступ до
них здійснюється через навігатор який
розміщений на сайті інституту і станом
на 17
питання викладені вебінари набрали понад
50 тисяч переглядів що говорить про
активне долучення вчителя саме до цих
процесів
задля всебічного розвитку та формування
наскрізних умінь здобувачів освіти у
співпраці із Lego foundation в Україні
проведено серію навчання щодо
впровадження в освітній процес закладів
освіти ігрових діяльностіних методів
навчання використання ігрових і
діяльності методів навчання надзвичайно
сьогодні важливе на адаптаційному циклі
базової середньої освіти і дозволяє
забезпечити наступність між початковою і
базовою середньою освітою
підготовлено на що хочу звернути увагу
путівник для вчителів 5-6 класів він є
логічним продовженням порадника для
вчителя нуш а його структура відповідає
положенням державного стандарту базової
середньої освіти наприклад у новій
редакції стандарту вперше зазначено що
мета базової середньої освіти
ґрунтується на ціннісних
орієнтирах відповідно у пу чому є розділ
присвячений практичний реалізації в
освітньому процесі наскрізного виховання
цінностей та якостей особистості новий
стандарт ґрунтується не на предметах А
на ключових компетентностях і на світ їх
результатих які ми має оволодіти кожен
випускник школи на певних етапах
навчання щоб бути успішним у житті
відповідно у путівнику продемонстровано
як вчитель на уроці використовуючи
вправи методи прийоми для розвитку
наскрізних умінь формує через них
компетентності
представлені методи реалізації
оцінювання навчальних досягнень учнів
5-6 класів у межах формувального та
підсумкового оцінювання
схарактеризовано особливості організації
продуктивної взаємодії в системі вчитель
учень технології навчання в парах і
невеликих групах в тому числі під час
застосування технологій дистанційного
навчання педагогіка партнерство
представлена як основа успішної
взаємодії із батьками здобу режим освіти
посібник теж розміщено у вільному
доступі як на сайті інституту так і на
сайті інституту модернізації змісту
освіти освіти на сайті інституту
продовжується наповнення рубрики нова
українська школа навчально-методичними
матеріалами
усе 281 матеріал на сьогодні 210 для
початкової освіти і 71 для базової
середньої освіти по галузях 15 червня
22-го року проведено круглий стіл очно
сцена нова українська школа підсумки та
сподівання де було відведено підсумки
першого навчального року пілотування нуш
у 5-х класах під час заходу
обговорювались наступні питання
формування в учнів ключових
компетентностей та навичок майбутнього
застосування нових підходів до
оцінювання навчальних досягнень учнів
формування партнерських взаємовідносин
між вчителями учнями та батьками
створення інклюзивного розвивального та
мотивуючого до навчання освітнього
простору окрім того вважаємо наголосити
на тому що у 22-му році Рой ППО
затверджено регіональне замовлення на
підвищення кваліфікації у кількості 20
тисяч 7507 осіб тобто із співпрацею із
Депа варіантом освіти із адміністрацією
з територіальними громадами Ми уже
визначилися в тому що
регіональне Замовлення буде сформовано і
вчителі отримують наші послуги із
підвищення кваліфікації
станом на 21 червня забезпечено
підвищення кваліфікації для 11
676 освітян навчання проводиться за
оновленими у грудні 21-го року
програмами в яких уся тематика приведена
повністю у відповідність до
концептуальних засад реформування
загальної середньої освіти під час
курсів у 22-му році значний акцент
робиться на висвітлення особливостей
реалізації нового державного стандарту
базової середньої освіти та роботи за
типовою освітньою програмою у результаті
військової інтервенції Російської
Федерації до України постало гостре
питання стану психологічного здоров'я
учасників освітнього процесу саме тому
Одним із головних завдань У кого стала
для повсякденна психологічна допомога та
емоційна підтримка учасників освітнього
процесу фактично з березня 22
-го року невідкладна психологічна і
соціальна підтримка для учасників
освітнього процесу крім того Хочу
зазначити що у нас іде активно з першого
березня навчання по домедичній
підготовці а також по тактичній медицині
і Хочу зазначити що з березня інститут
став гуманітарним і соціальним хабом для
внутрішньо переміщених осіб із березня
по сьогоднішній день можна сказати що у
нас в інституті було зареєстровано понад
750 внутрішньо переміщених осіб разом із
дітьми Як дошкільного так і шкільного
віку на сьогодні в інституті проживає 69
осіб з якими ми працюємо саме і в
освітній і в соціальній складовій це
допомагає адаптувати наші програми
адаптувати людей до
життя не під вистрілами обстрілами і це
співпраця яка сьогодні говорить про міц
освіту міць України і все спільними
зусиллями ми робимо для перемоги всі
матеріали є на сайті на сторінці
Facebook Інститутській на
telegram-каналі і є у вільному доступі
від себе особисто від колективу
інституту хочу щиро подякувати всім
колегам які знаходяться у горнелі
військових дій які міцно тримають
освітній фронт який тримають
ідеологічний ідейний фронт Дякую всім
колегам за співпрацю у гуманітарній і
освітній сфері за колегіальні підтримку
і хочу сказати що такий важкий період
він насправді показує світлих людей і
дає шлях у перспективне майбутнє України
все буде Україна буде обов'язково
перемога і освіта буде нас є одним
головним фронтом для нашої Перемоги
Дякую за співпрацю дякую дякую
вам за цікавий змістовні виступ Я
доповнення хочу також Сказати що
сьогодні виникне питання набагато про
освітнього простору для 5-6 класів
коли виступав говорив те що на сайті
інституту єсть інтерактивна виставка і
Отак ми рекомендуємо директорів знайти
на цю виставку і подивитись Ми там
постаралися представити ті компанії які
сьогодні можуть вам
надати послуги і закупівлі меблів
обладнання і так далі так що
використовуйте ці матеріали які є для
того щоб наші навчальні заклади отримали
нормальну нормальну таку матеріальну
базу в нас дуже довгий час інститути в
Міністерства співпраці з академією ми
спільного працюємо спільно ведемо
наукові дослідну роботу і тому
Я хочу заради слова запросити свого
колегу Тамару михайлівну сорочан це
директора центрального інституту
післядипломної освіти університету
менеджменту освіти Академії Наук
педагогічної комісії Національної
академії педагогічних наук України прошу
вас Тамара Михайлівна і виступити і з
виступом по професійний розвиток
педагогічної еліти будь ласка
дякую дуже шановний Юрій Іванович І
хотілося би розпочати свій виступ із
обговорення проблеми що ми розуміємо під
педагогічної елітою України інтуїтивно
ми розуміємо але мені хотілося б
уточнити це поняття що ми говоримо про
амбасадорів цінностей євроінтеграції
нашого українського суспільства держави
Україна особистісного і професійного
розвитку кожного учасника освітнього
процесу це безумовно лідери освіти які
представлені сьогодні на конференції це
велика
кількість вчителів велика спільнота
освітян які підтримують реформи
підтримують інновації це провайдери
інновації і реформ Я хотіла би звернути
увагу якраз на цінності наші спільні
цінності України і Європи і саме по цих
цінностях проходить кордон той За який
воює наші збройні сили України і який
підтримуємо ми єдиним освітнім фронтом
це цінності дуже сильно відрізняються
наші цінності життя Незалежності Свободи
демократії культурної спадщини
патріотизму безумовно ми поділяємо їх із
європейською спільнотою до якої прагнемо
що є ключовими джерелами інновацій в
освіті саме тих які підтри
підтримує еліта освітньої еліта України
це самі цінності про які я сказала це
команди які працюють і в нуш і в тому
числі в інших закладах освіти це лідери
освіти це цифрові технології взагалі
освітня технології які ми зараз можемо
назвати те хто поєднання цифрових і
освітніх технологій і це безумовно
проблема якості освіти так от щодо
інноваційних технологій вони звичайно не
можуть бути розділені окремо кожна але
можна сказати що
технології поєднання цифри і
технології освітніх це технології
менеджменту успіху адже саме на це
спрямовані зараз управлінські впливи це
Experience технології тобто ті які
будуються на основі досвіду який дуже
важливий в освітній галузі це
технології результативної акти
діяльності специфічного наставництва
супервізії менторства і тощо це
культуротворчі технології які розвивають
культуру України нашої вітчизняні
здобутки і це безумовно саме освіта яка
робить учителів педагогів активними у
процесі навчання зараз найбільш
популярною є відкрита освіта про яку
говорили всі без виключення попередньої
доповідачі яка дає можливість
доступності створення бази знань
використання ресурсів вибору можливостей
мотивації для навчання
безперервності і саме та технологічного
оснащення так от тепер коротко про
етих поєднання цифрових і освітніх
технологій перш за все це створення
цифрових екосистем це цифрові двійники
закладів освіти особливо необхідні саме
у такий час який ми зараз переживаємо це
університети дистанційні курси
віртуальні кафедри Digital have тощо
Хочу зазначити що всі вони представлені
в досліді центрального інституту
післядипломної освіти університет у
менеджменту освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України хочу
звернутися до колег із обласних
інститутів післядипломної освіти із
словами подяки що саме український
відкритий університет післядипломної
освіти який успішно функціонує і веде
навчання з 2019 року розвивається був
створений завдяки саме спільноті
закладів інститутів післядипломної
освіти
зараз дуже популярна результативна
активність Тобто це цілеспрямована Та
яка дає конкретні результати щодо
розвитку навичок і тут
зазначені ці активності які
використовуються теж сьогодні це все
прозвучало І дуже важлива підтримка саме
такої результативної активності через
інноваційні методики професійного
розвитку вчителів
в центральному інституті післядипломної
освіти університету менеджменту освіти
також було підтримано педагогів під час
військової агресії ми провели акцію на
підтримку і трансформації професійного
розвитку педагогічних
науково-педагогічних працівників і
керівників освіти
працівники центрального інституту
безплатно для вчителів провели
близько 60 різних заходів і учасниками
цих заходів стали близько п'яти тисяч
наших шановних освітян це крім тих тисяч
які ми підвищуємо кваліфікацію
відповідно до держзамовлення і тих трьох
тисяч які пройшли навчання в
українському відкритому університеті
післядипломної освіти Ми назвали свою
акцію переможні обрії освіти тому що
віримо в перемогу освіти і професійний
розвиток еліти
освіти України саме у Європейському
форматі Слава Україні разом Ідемо до
перемоги Дякую за увагу Дякуємо і вам
Тамара Михайлівна за змістовну чітку
чіткий виступ дякую вам і я думаю що
далі співпраця
до слова запрошується
конкурентку Дмитро Володимирович який
виступить і познайомить нас із питанням
психологічної допомоги у сфері освіти
України запрошую вас Дмитро
Володимирович це заступник голови
асоціації інноваційної та цифрової
освіти
Доброго дня колеги
Всіх вітаю і радий презентувати навіть
не один на два проекти перше - це
безпосередньо екосистема психологічної
допомоги у сфері освіти України а другий
також дуже важливий проект для сфери
освіти - це система профорієнтації Отже
почнемо з екосистеми психологічної
допомоги у сфері освіти України які
робиться в міністерством освіти України
інституту модернізації змісту освіти
спільно з нашою асоціацією інноваційні
та цифрової освіти будь ласка наступний
слайд
на жаль на жаль в ці умови в цих умовах
питання психологічної допомоги є вкрай
актуальним ви знаєте що за
[музика]
міністр
міністра охорони здоров'я України і
сказав про те що
понад 15 мільйонів українців будуть
змушені шукати психологічні допомоги
через наслідки війни тому ми також усі
вірусити повинні це питання дуже
серйозне системно відпрацювати і
організувати таку таку психологічну
допомогу тому місія цього проекту
полягає в тому щоб надати практичні
навички всім дотичним до сфери освіти це
освітяни перш за все які не мають
базової психологічної освіти шкільний
психологи учасникам освітнього процесу
то звичайно їх батькам також щодо першої
психологічної допомоги емоційної
підтримки стресу стійкості на основі
найкращих міжнародних практик зокрема
гостей дуже важливо щоб ми не вигадували
велосипеда
практиками перш за все які вже
проденстрували свою ефективність в інших
країнах і багато років і затверджені
міжнародним інституціями певними Отже
декілька кроків які ми вже зробили
декілька кроків які будуть зроблені
найближчим часом для формування такої
екосистеми в сфері освіти Отже крок
перший ми створили спільно курс
підвищення кваліфікації для освітян який
називається перша психологічна допомога
учасникам особами
по-перше навіть навіть музичні супровід
є Отже курс створено за моделлю
змішаного навчання буде для них який
складається з мультимедійних уроків у
форматі Score які ми робили спільно з
психологами рільського університету з
Ізраїлю країна яка має досить великий
досвід в таких питаннях
друге - це методичний матеріал кращих
світових практик і Третє - це практичні
тренінг які чекають читають фахівці
клінічні психологи зокрема за
методичними Посібниками також
ознайомлять з рекомендаціями щодо
перенаправлення міжвідомчого постійного
комітету це дуже важливо правильно
перенаправзити дітей які потребують
окремої додаткової уваги до профільних
фахівців і такому також участі Цей курс
а він створений також спільно з
інститутом хопкінса - це провідна
американська установа з психології і
тому тут задіяні максимально весь
міжнародний досвід який сьогодні може
бути задіяний для цього питання будь
ласка другий
Отже зараз відбувається другий етап це
етап навчання
по хорошому Цей курс повинен пройти всі
освітяни які сьогодні є в Україні як
вихователі дитячих садків
вчителів викладачів вузів шкільний
психолог керівники навчальних закладів
повинні знати і вміти
надавати першу психологічну допомогу Ми
сподіваємось що це так і вийде вже на
сьогоднішній день Цей курс дуже
відповідальності тягне відносяться За що
ми Дуже щиро вдячні Їм тільки за один
місяць вже понад 5 тисяч офіціан вже
успішно завершили навчання і отримали
сертифікат підвищення кваліфікації 30
годин який передбачено тому що не
затверджений вченою радою інституту
модернізації змісту освіти і понад 10
000 офіціан вже проходять Цей курс і це
всього за один місяць ще раз кажу ми
щиро вдячність за таку відповідальну
позицію чекаємо ще більше освітян з
країни на цих курсах тому що пропоную
наступний слайд подивитися Отже
наступний крок третій які якраз
почнеться з нового навчального року ті
освітян які пройдуть Цей курс вони
зможуть вже надавати першу першу
психологічну допомогу і робити
перенаправлення осіб які потребують
окремої уваги до професійної психологів
і останні 4 крок це як додаткова
можливість Але вона дуже важлива це так
звана супервізія це методологічно та
консультаційна підтримка освітян у
процесі надання першої педагогічної
допомоги професійними клінічної
психологами на над цим Зараз ми працюємо
щоб ця
супервізія ця підтримка методична була
забезпечена також всім освітянам Які
будуть цього потребувати Окрім цього
створюються повним ходом курси для з
підвищення кваліфікації для шкільних
психологів це окрема
категорія яка буде надаватись навчання
далі освітні курси зі стійкості для
батьків відеоуроків від відомих
психологів які будуть демонструвати
прості та ефективні вправи так звані
психологічні 5-хвилинки які допоможуть
учням залишатись в ресурсному стані під
час навчального процесу Таким чином
створюється повноцінна екосистема і
ефективна психологічної допомоги у сфері
освіти України
Це була перша презентація і тоді я
попрошу Коротко розказати ще про другу в
рамках відведеного часу Отже
всеукраїнський проект профорієнтації та
побудови кар'єри обери професію своїм
мрії проект який покликаний також його
організатори Міністерства освіти і науки
України інституту модернізації змісту
освіти освітніх і міста Києва та
асоціація
інноваційно-цифрової освіти проект
покликаний
забезпечити системну профорієнтацію і
цей знаєте як соціальний міст між ліфт
між навчальним закладами та ринком праці
це дуже важливо
актуальність цього питання і у звичайний
час і у військовий також дуже великий
тому що ми не можемо втратити покоління
дітей які зараз навчаються у старших
класах і обирають або не обирають
свідомо ту чи іншу професію
за офіційною статистикою понад 50%
українських випускників працюють не за
фахом це дуже велика проблема яку треба
терміново вирішити і саме з 2021 року це
питання почало вирішувати Саме через цей
системний проект був пілотний рід він
прийшов досить успішний і зараз цей
проект подовжений надалі Отже ми
говоримо що про місію що запустити
ефективну соціальний ліфт який з'єднає
заклади освіти та ринок праці і надати
можливість молоді свідомо побудувати
індивідуальну траєкторію подальшого
навчання та розвитку кар'єри на
сьогоднішній день вже пройшли всі
необхідні нормативні документи для цього
перше це включення проекту До
стратегічних нормативно- документів МОНу
це програма дій уряду до 2024 року
оперативний план мон на
2021-2022 роки також є окремий наказ
Міністерства освіти і науки України і це
все повинен призвести до системного
запуску ефективного соціального ліфта в
сфері освіти
будь ласка наступний слайд перед тим як
робити цей проєкт ми безумовно дуже
ретельно вивчили міжнародний досвід ви
бачите тільки просто як географію
декілька країн провідних це і США і
Китай і Німеччина і Швеція і
Франція Ми дуже багато ретельно вивчав
цей досвід і глобальні мережі Юнеско все
що сьогодні є
інноваційного і ефективного
профорієнтацію ввійшло найкращі в наш
проект Звичайно він адаптований до
реальної України будь ласка наступний
слайд
алгоритм наступний тобто є платформа яка
вже створена і там є 5 кроків Тобто ми
створили такий інноваційний
замінник
людині якій може надавати послуги по
профорієнтації вести дітей незважаючи де
дитина знаходиться чи в Україні чи поза
межами Чи входить вона в очну школу чи
навчається дистанційно-сімейна тощо
тобто крок перший - це профорієнтаційно
тестування на основі штучного інтелекту
ми створили унікальну систему яка дійсно
визначає типи особистості типи інтелекту
- це здібності дитини і прив'язує її до
по професії визначає найкращі професії
які підходять дитини за її здібностями з
базою понад тисячі професій крок другий
- це консультації кар'єрних радників які
відбуваються за інноваційну технологію
перегорнутого кол-центру
це все безкоштовно відбувається Третє -
це навчання як вірно складати ми успішно
пройти співбесіду того що те що потрібно
буде в майбутньому
фахівцю і четвертий Крок онлайн
екскурсії на провідні підприємства
України ми дійсно відвідуємо найкраще
підприємства по всій країні робимо дуже
такий
інноваційні цікаві екскурсії Які Я
сподіваюсь дітям дуже цікаво дивитись і
бачити обирати собі професію або
компанію або організацію причому там не
тільки комерційні професії там багато
робітничих професій там багато
соціальних професій
екскурсії і зоопарк є і
в інші там метрополітен наприклад Ну і в
школу є також Ну і звичайно і інші
професії крок п'ятий - це скоро років
щодо актуальних професій де дитина може
і батьки ознайомитись з понад 100
професій які ми створили на сьогоднішній
день і обрати найкращу і все це
завершується тим що формується
інтерактивне резюме кожного учня Це
дійсно унікальна штука яка дозволяє
дитині вести своє резюме з школи і потім
коли буде додавати це резюме якусь на
все життя воно вони прямо на сайті
розташоване буде додавати потім де вона
вчилась потім перше місце роботи тощо
тощо будь-які часто резюме можна бути в
майбутньому роздрукувати і прийти на
співбесіду або надіслати роботодавцю
Тобто це унікальна річ так і в Європі
такого нема тобто після цього можна
зробити свідомий вибір або навчальний
заклад
університет або
професійно-технічне училище Ну і далі
про це влаштування Тобто це такий
соціальний ліфт звичайно ми розуміємо що
потрібно готувати безпосередньо фахівців
з цього питання яких На жаль сьогодні
дуже мало професійних в Україні тому
паралельно було запущено в рамках цього
цієї системи профорієнтації школи
кар'єрного консультанта це системна
підготовка
фахівців з сфери освіти Тобто це
підвищення кваліфікації з профорієнтації
для вчителів дошкільних психологів і
таким чином будується отака система
роботи по поверхнікації будь ласка
наступний сайт
це як я вже казав що
ми сподіваємося що через деякий час
стандартне резюме увійде у минуле як і
кнопочні телефони буде саме люди в
Україні як мінімум використовувати саме
такий інтерактивний резюме який має крім
звичайних даних дуже важливу інформацію
яку формує саме штучний інтелект та саме
типу особистості типу інтелекту
рекомендовані професії саме це на
сьогоднішній день дуже важливо для
роботодавців і це робить будь-яку людину
конкурентноспроможною на ринку праці в
будь-якій країні світу до речі зараз це
питання ми проговорюємо і з колегами з
Польщі вони дуже зацікавлені в тому щоб
така система запрацювала і у них будь
ласка наступний слайд
ну коротко про результати які вже от за
один рік досягнуті запущена сайт
всеукраїнського проекту з профорієнтації
та побудови кар'єри
курси підвищення кваліфікації у школі
кар'єрного радника прийшли понад 4
тисячі вчителів та шкільних психологів
проведена понад 20 тисяч
профорієнтаційних тестувань на основі
штучного інтелекту та понад 5 тисяч
консультацій кар'єрних радників зняти 50
онлайн екскурсій на провідні
підприємства України розроблене
уроки по 100 більш ніж 100 професій ну
інформаційна вклад компанія за один рік
склав Понад мільйон осіб це і учасники
освітнього процесу і освітян і їх
батьків наступну слайд будь ласка
На цьому я дуже вам вдячний сподіваюсь
всі два проекти будуть продовжувати Я
дуже вдячні міністерству освіти України
і інституту модернізації змісту освіти в
особі його директора Євгена бажинкова за
і Пані фляковського Ольга яка також нам
дуже-дуже допомагає всіх питаннях я
сподіваюсь що все вийде і все буде
Україна дякую дякую Дмитро Володимирович
продовжуємо наш наше засідання до слова
Запрошуємо Діану романовську яка розкаже
про психологічну допомогу учасникам
освітнього процесу на прикладі
чернівеччини будь ласка
Доброго дня
вельмишановні колеги учасники
Міжнародної конференції дуже хочу
подякувати всім організаторам за таку
можливість
виступити і за увагу до психологічної
служби система освіти взагалі в нашій
країні тому що я вважаю що їх діяльність
наша діяльність психологів в центрі
практичної психології соціальної
інституті післядипломної педагогічної
освіти за останні шість воєнні місяців
воєнних місяців
надзвичайно одна з тих яка найбільше
трансформувалася тому що фахівці
психології які були мали спеціалізацію
вікової та педагогічної психології
загальної психології ми
переформатовуємося і далі І
переформатовувалися в фахівців з
кризової психології екстремальної
психології вчимося і вже надаємо і першу
психологічну допомогу і спеціалізовану
психотерапевтичну допомогу за потреби і
стаємо фахівцями вже збереження
повноцінними психічного здоров'я хотіла
би продемонструвати звичайно вам свою
досвід роботи нашої області як у нас це
було як наша психологічна служба
працювала коли це все знаєте ці дні
почалося коли це все почалося наш центр
практичної психології Ми зрозуміли що
маємо бути справжніми лідерами в таких
невизначених ситуаціях кризи і
згуртувати навколо себе всю спільноту
фахівців і психологів шкільних і
соціальних педагогів і дати їм ту
впевненість силу інструменти і
науково-методичні супровід для того щоб
допомагати
було кому допомагати і зараз ця потреба
у психологічній допомозі вона не зникає
вона і буде
продовжуватися і продовжується і я думаю
що це є дуже важливо в діяльності саме
наших структурних підрозділів
психологічних систем післядипломної
педагогічної освіти першим кроком що ми
розробили в перші тижні це ми
проаналізували який у нас є вже
професійний інструментарій адже він нас
з 14-го року тривала І ми мали
напрацювання і ми опиралися на них і це
були напрацювання і фахів для нашого
центру і фахівців психологів науковців
практиків України і ми мали свої такі
напрацювання які отримали ігри в
Міністерство освіти і були схвалені
вченої ради українського
науково-методичного центру практично
психології соціальної роботи
Національної академії педагогічних наук
Ну і звичайно ми користувалися тими
практичними наробками які вже були
опрацьовані з 14-го року для того щоб
допомога і
внутрішньо переміщеним особам і нашим
здобувачам освіти і всім педагогічним
працівникам які в лютому березні
відчували високий рівень тривоги страху
також зв'язку з ситуацією ми створили
спеціальний веб-сайт нашого центру і з
підтримки адміністрації
нашого інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти Ми створили закладку
вкладку на сайті інституту психологічна
допомога педагогам і тут розміщували усі
ті ресурси які були потрібно для того
щоб одразу швидко і практично собі
допомогти стабілізувати і допомагати
усім хто цього потребує але Ми зрозуміли
що просто методичних рекомендацій для
самостійного опрацювання в форматі
формальної освіти це недостатньо і тоді
ми організували серію
таких методичних заходів які носили
навчально-практичне орієнтацію назвали
їх навчально-методичній коворкінги які
складалися з двох частин Перша година
навчання друга година практично
опрацювання тих методів які зараз можуть
бути активними якими ми вже володіли або
окремі фахівці нашого центру нашої
області і ось уже 9 березня нами був
проведений такий перший коворкінг до
якого долучилися всього 58 фахівців які
були Скажімо так тоді в строю і в
ресурсі допомагати іншим але вже на
наступний у нас було по можливостям зуму
100 і всі наступні коворкинги які ось
тут ми демонструємо з різними темами ми
починаючи з першого записували їх і
створили таку медіатеку яка також
розміщена на у вкладці на сайті
інституту післядипломної педагогічної
освіти Чернівецької області і мали
можливість усі практичні психологи
соціальні педагоги а серпня місяця ми
вже долучаємо і педагогічних працівників
вчителів різних предметів до спільного
такого перегляду навчального матеріалу і
це знаєте стало таким дуже гарним
ресурсом для всіх фахівців які спочатку
не змогли долучитись але маючи таку
медіатеку ми можемо самостійно Пройти
навчання і ми тому поєднали тут
неформальну і формальну освіту Також ми
створили відеотеку психологічних вправ
які будуть допомагати педагогам в
проведенні і помагали вже педагогам
проведенні онлайн уроків для
стабілізації психоемоційного стану і
хотілось би сказати що ми продовжували
це активна робота була
весною але влітку завдяки Департаменту
освіти і науки Чернівецької Ода ми
спільно зробили такий навчальний проект
з за підтримки фонду Parimatch з
коаліцією ізраїльської коаліцією травми
і вже пройшли у нас частина фахівців
пройшли таке фахове терапевтичне
навчання
ми змогли
вибрати і експортувати 120 кращих
практик фахівців які б застосовуються в
закладах освіти нашої області і які саме
допомагають і вже набули ефективності і
отримали схвальний відгуки педагогічної
спільноти І які використовуються в
системі проведення
уроків і позаурочний час ми також
зрозуміли що потрібно вносити зміни і
формальну складову освіти і тому
програми підвищення кваліфікації для
працівників психологічної служби були
внесені зміни був переформатований
третій модуль саме по психологічній
травмі на 30 годин і був
переформатований спецкур за вибором
гармонізації психологічного здоров'я
розвиток життєстійкості стресостійкості
який офіційно у нас зараз впроваджується
і завдяки якому ми вже в березні в
травні могли долучити до такого
формального навчання
кризової психології шість груп фахівців
психологічної служби і за спецкурсом у
нас долучалися педагогічні працівники і
одна група педагогічних працівників
працювала саме в той тиждень Коли це все
почалося і коли ми в четвер
[музика]
Ось цього повномасштабного наступу
зібралися онлайн з педагогами то Ми
зрозуміли і відібрали ті практики які
найбільш дієві науково-методичний
супровід якийсь здійснює центр
практичної психології соціальної роботи
він також Ми зрозуміли має заключатися і
в тому що ми маємо відслідковувати і
отримувати зворотний зв'язок від того як
ми провели навчання як це реалізується в
закладах освіти які виникають труднощі і
що ще потрібно тому ми розробили і
провели таке ще онлайн дослідження щоб
зрозуміти ось наша фахова спільнота як
вона практично реалізує і надає
психологічну допомогу і були опитування
прийняли участь більше майже 70%
закладів освіти і нашої області
представників з них і ми визначили що
Весною ми надавали ми надали допомогу
50% із тих внутрішньо переміщеннях які
перебували проживали в наших закладах
освіти які були на території наших
територіальних громад Ми проаналізували
з якими проблемами найбільше зверталися
і наші учасники освітнього процесу і
діти батьки дорослі ВПО і ми бачимо що
все-таки весною переважали емоційні
порушення страх страх за себе страх за
близьких хто ми виснаження відновлення
почуття безпеки у учасників нашого
освітнього процесу був період адаптації
і страху стосовно сирен і також наші
психологи працювали з цим і ми вели
спеціальний такий блог в якому
підтримували роз'яснювали і допомагали
зорієнтуватися в цих запитах що ми
можемо ще додати як це покращити ми
визначили найбільш дієві практики як
професійний інструментарій яким ми
користувалися для того щоб поділитися
різних фахівцями які ще не долучилися до
процесу психологічної допомоги тому що
це теж було поступово хтось виїжджав і
хтось потім повертався і найбільш
стабілізаційними фахівців закладу освіти
визначили все-таки дихальні практики
часто і ефективно використовувались
арт-терапевтичні практики
стабілізація тілесного стану
і різні релаксаційні методики і звичайно
те що застосовує педагогічну спільнота і
гігротерапія але ми і
сформували групу
фахівців які обізнані вже
психотерапевтичній допомозі які
застосовували такі терапевтичні техніки
який і Basic pH і психодравматичні і
есист протоколи і які допомагали в
роботі і зараз у нас такий існує
своєрідний хаб де ми обмінюємося
інформацією і
перенаправляємо відповідно до потреб тих
наших здобувачів освіти батьків
відповідно до того яка спеціалізація у
наших фахівців тобто Нам вдалося
впорядкувати
організаційно-логістичну і
інструментаційно стані мій слайд хотіла
би поділитись тим що най Я думаю що
найрезультативнішою в роботі нашого
науково-методичного супроводу це
вироблений єдиний алгоритм протокол який
яких трошки не вистачає фахівцям
психологічної служби для роботи за яким
працює практичний психолог і соціальний
педагог в закладі освіти коли надає
психологічну допомогу Дякую за увагу
дякую пані Діана запрошую пані Олена до
ринку це директорка
навчально-методичного центру
психологічної служби в системі освіти
Чернігівської області
прошу вас пані Олена
Добрий день шановні колеги переказую вам
щирі колегіальні вітання від
психолочини Зі стін нашого рідного
Чернігів з інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти імені Ушинського до
якого ми дякуючи Богу і ЗСУ мали
можливість повернутися хоча в гості до
себе поки що не запрошуємо бо
Чернігівщина продовжує потерпати від
ворожих обстрілів зруйновано
велику освітню закладів що велика
кількість здобувачів освіти їхніх
батьків перебуває як внутрішньо
переміщені особи за кордоном в областях
західної Центральної України під вашою
колеги психологічної та емоційною опікою
За що ми вам Щиро дякуємо розуміючи
об'єм навантаження на практичних
психологів закладі освіти ваших регіонів
спочатку
війни в нашому регіоні запит на
психологічну допомогу відчутно зріст і
це прогнозовано дорослі батьки та
вчителі стикнулися з такими реакціями
власне та дитячою психіки на війну з
якими впоратися без допомоги спеціаліста
було складно у перші місяці російської
навали найефективнішими виявилися саме
дистанційні форми надання психологічної
допомоги адже через обстріли робота
офлайн не була завжди безпечною
фахівцями використовувалися усі можливі
медіа-засоби наприклад було записано
десятки коротких просвітницьких
відеозвернення адресованих батьками
педагоги розміщено в батьківських та
педагогічних професійних спільнотах
Viber Messenger та Facebook
виступи на
країнах тили та радіоканалах
відеозвернення на YouTube з
рекомендаціями та порадами як допомогти
собі дитині пережити кризову ситуацію
цікавими інноваціями виявилися створення
чад-ботів зрозумів підтримує допоможу
електронної дошки якесь психологічної
підтримки соціально-педагогічного
супроводу В умовах воєнного стану це
інновації створення психологами закладів
професійної освіти сотні телефонних
консультацій з батьками та педагогами і
чому цю інформацію було адресовано
більше дорослим бо дорослий є фактором
стабільності та безпеки для дитини як у
літаку з першого кисневу маску надягаємо
собі потім дитині на піклуючись про себе
не врятуємо її
психологічна компетентність батьків
педагогів знання з першої психологічної
допомоги є виходячи з нашого досвіду і з
досвіду останніх місяців наших колег
пріоритетними для просвітницької
діяльності психологічної служби зокрема
та для освітянської спільноти загалом як
і говорили попередні спікери про це
говорили про ці питання в умовах системи
післядипломної педагогічної освіти за
рахунок підвищення рівня психологічної
компетентності педагогів є можливість
опосередковано формувати обізнаність
щодо стресостійкості резидентності
здобувачів освіти та батьків зокрема на
базі нашого інституту розгорнуто
просвітницьку компанію для педагогів з
метою актуалізації саме тих знань та
навичок психологічної допомоги які є
необхідними в умовах війни з цією метою
на сайті інституту нашим центром було
спільно з кафедрою створено рубрику
запитань психолога в якій зібрані
корисні посилання про які сьогодні вже
говорилося я не буду на них зупинятися
ми їм володіємо і вони є у доступі саме
розраховані для підвищення психологічної
компетентності педагогічних працівників
звичайно поза Тім в рубриці запитати
психолога було розміщено велика
кількість матеріалів які ми можемо
скористатися самі і можемо запропонувати
для користування нашим колегам у
також зміни були внесені у розширення
тематики відповідно до реалії у
запланованій семінари вебінари
майстер-класи авторські тематичні курси
я не буду зараз цього всього
перераховувати тому що здебільшого
психологічна служба України саме
користується Тіми програмами Тіми
уже розробленими
народками які можна користуватись якими
можна користуватися і у військовий час
але все одно більшість ліг потребує
доопрацювання потребує адаптації і
потребує звичайно високого рівня
професійного від спеціалістів всі
спеціалісти нашого центру зокрема є
практиками ми входимо до складу
мобільної груп психологічної допомоги
та надаємо допомогу консультаційному
кабінеті які функціонують на базі нашого
інституту і це було важливим чинником
мирний час вона було ще більше означення
в умовах війни за відгуками колег За
останні півроку ми вони мабуть
найцінніший практичний фаховий досвід
теоретичні знання коли є з багатьох
фахових питань стали підґрунтям для
практики і ти сподівами мої відмічаєш
так от як виглядає панічна атака про яку
ти говорив на лекціях і це є сумний але
цінний досвід для психологів для
педагогів для батьків і для дітей але
цінний за умови його прийняття
правильного проживання відпрацювання
тієї травматизації і це вже не в рамках
компетенції педагога який би рівень
обізнаності з питань першої
психологічної допомоги він не мав перша
психологічна допомога не це не про
психологічну фахову допомогу ми про
професійний психологічне консультування
цей речі можливі в комплексі і не є
взаємозамінними важливо сформувати в
суспільстві стійке переконання в тому що
психологічні проблеми потребують фахової
психологічної допомоги і вміння та
бажання її отримати говорить про високий
рівень відповідальності та свідомості
його громадян щодо рівня Підготовки їх
фахівців психологічної служби у системі
освіти і знову ж досвіду останніх
місяців психолог має володіти знаннями з
кризового консультування і це
обов'язково вікових психологічних
особливостей які у дитини 5-6 років
можуть відрізнятися кардинально наразі
на мій погляд сформовано у нас потужний
банк ресурсів які були підготовлені
відділом наукового навчально-методичного
забезпечення змісту
освіти та виховної роботи модернізації
змісту освіти українські
науково-методичним центром всі вони
розміщені у нас на блозі нашого центру і
всі розміщуються на групах
навчально-методичного центру щойно було
поновлено роботою інституту і ми дуже
щасливі були вернутися на свої робочі
місця на базі інституту відразу були
проведені
ряд заходів які ви бачите перед собою як
навички кризового консультування так і
по-новому актуалізувалися програма
Особливо особисто гідність безпека життя
громадянська позиція дуже рекомендуємо
її до впровадження і в інших областях
за представництва дитячого фонду он
Юнеско проходять навчання діти та війна
навчання технікам зцілення практичні
психологи нашої області всієї України Ця
програма Вона є дуже важливою коли
більш-менш стала спокійна у нас ситуація
в області ми відразу зорієнтувалися і
виокремили діти теми які є наразі
найактуальнішими цей співпраця з
підрозділами дисинс забезпечення прав
дитини в освітньому процесі був
проведений великий масштабний наші
колеги долучилися з такою радістю Це був
настільки приємно що люди хочуть бажають
і готові до цієї співпраці до цих хоча б
віртуальних зустрічей і теми які
теми які піднімалися на
нашому зібранні наразі є дуже
актуальними і Наприклад одна із них я
працювати з людьми які пережили окупацію
та були в ресурсі алгоритми дій дитячі
страхи порушені війною техніки
відновлення ідентичності робота з
колективною травмою ви зараз перед собою
на слайдах бачите авторів цих програм
розумієте рівень підготовки їх за що ми
їм дуже вдячні але що важливо колеги
міжнародний досвід який наше психологи
отримали
у ході навчання
за
участю у навчальному тренінгу психічне
здоров'я та психосоціальна підтримка які
проводили міжнародну громадську
організацію афінська церковна допомога
захід проходив офлайн і хочу вам сказати
цікаві відгук поділитися такими своїми
реакціями на відгу
який сказав нас приємно вразив рівень
підготовки учасників ми не очікували
такого і як висновок коли я хочу сказати
що нам Звичайно є чого навчатися але
Важливо не допускати знецінення власного
досвіду і применшення власних
можливостей чужому навчається Свого не
цурайся про структуру психологічної
служби звичайно Як
сталося у нашій області у багатьох інших
областях як були
розтрощені будівлі так і була можна
сказати безорієнтована на якийсь час і
психологічна служба до цього часу нам
потрібно на початку навчального року
зібрати чіткі дані про те наскільки
зараз може функціонувати Наскільки в
ресурсі знаходяться наші спеціалісти
тому ми розробили От таку Google форму я
дякую вам за увагу Дякую за можливість
долучитися до такого зібрання думаю мій
моя презентація буде корисним корисною
тим хто її зацікавиться Чернігівщина
вірить в перевагу Ми чекаємо вас до себе
в гості навал як тільки закінчиться
війна вона закінчиться Миру всім все
буде Україна дякую пані Олена запрошення
обов'язково прийде чищину і зараз до
слова запрошую пані Оксану Рома це
керівниця освітніх дітей Lego будь ласка
дякую за вступну частину і доброго
дня прошу надати мені доступ для
демонстру компанії екрану
та Дякую У нас є доступ вже є Бачу Дякую
Зараз моя презентація з'явиться на
екрані
тож вітання усім освітянам і відмінною
особливістю сьогоднішньої конференції є
те що це конференція з великим болем і
сумом у серці але в той же час
нескореної вірою і бажанням кожного
освітянина докласти ще більше зусиль
максимальних зусиль для того щоб
зберегти усе те що ми напрацювали з вами
роками і навпаки наважитися на ті
рішення на які Можливо в мирний час і не
наважилися і сьогодні партнерство між
державою громадським сектором
міжнародної спільнотою батьківською
спільнотою навколо вектору і траєкторії
руху освіти України стає ще більш
відчутним і потрібним увесь світ
сьогодні відслідковуєте куди рухається
освіта України як Вона рухається і я
хочу зараз звернутися до декілька
генеративів до декілька таких звернень
зробити до світових медіа які говорять
про те що українська освіта витримує
виклики війни в системі освіти вдалося
перебудуватися відповідно до потреб
воєнного часу мільйони українських дітей
продовжують
всупереч війні І от саме це слово
всупереч стає тим завдяки якому ми
рухаємося і рухаємося не тільки в рамках
гуманітарних потреб як цей правило
відбувається у контекстах там де
відбувається війна в рамках нашої
великої мрії проте як би ми хотіли
бачити освіту України тому сьогодні
гуманітарний компонент який пропонується
і державою і громадським сектором
міжнародної спільнотою має бути не
окремою лінією підтримки а органічно
вплетеним нашу цілісну візію поступу
систему освіти України саме тому Lego
foundtion маючи вже понад
дванадцятирічний досвід співпраці із
міністерством освіти і науки України
наразі продовжує реалізацію усіх тих
проєктів ініціатив які були розпочаті в
дошкіллі початковій базовій школі
післядипломної освіти вищої освіти але
ми поглиблюємо і підсилюємо ці проєкти
гуманітарним компонентом партнерство
післядипломної освітою Оскільки ми в
рамках цієї локації сьогодні працюємо це
означає розбудову екосистемного бачення
реалізації вищезазначених проєктів і
надання саме інститутам післядипломної
освіти ключової ролі в укоріненій і
забезпеченні сталості інтеграції ігрових
і діяльнісних методів навчання і
взаємодії з дітьми Як міжнародна
інституція яка має вже тривалий досвід
співпраці з Україною я хочу зараз
зупинитися на ключових проєктах і яким
чином ми їх підсилюємо і де будемо з
вами далі співпрацювати проект сприяння
освіти в дошкіллі 300 закладів
дошкільної освіти Ми надалі з ними
працюємо 15 областей України але ми не
зупиняємося на цьому проекті ми його
Далі розширюємо будемо надавати
педагогам професійний розвиток
систематично-методичну підтримку і
сьогодні дуже важливо мати не тільки
якісний І цікавий контент а дуже важливо
щоб цей контент який отримують педагоги
він був ресурсним перед усім для
педагогів для батьків для дітей для
дітей і для всіх родин тому разом
тому я цьогоріч ці 300 закладів про які
я згадую разом з 20-ма інститутами
післядипломної освіти будуть забезпечені
від фонду також технічними засобами
навчання ноутбуками для того щоб за
необхідності продовження онлайн
модальності взаємодії із дітьми або із
слухачами у вас були на це ресурси Окрім
цього ми як фундація спільно із
шведської організацією Пеппі пелс
пропонуємо таку комплексний пакет
програма соціально-емоційного розвитку
дітей веселі друзі яка буде доступна з
жовтня місяця в Україні яка включає
мобільні застосунок цикли 16
мультфільмів яких про друзів методичні
рекомендації для педагогів набори з
іграшок для взаємодії з дітьми поради
щодо імплементації інструменту в
освітній процес цей додаток буде
доступний для завантаження не тільки в
Україні а також для батьків які
знаходяться із дітьми поза межами
України абсолютно в безкоштовному
варіанті
Окрім цього ми пропонуємо нашим
педагогам і дуже хочемо поділитися цими
ресурсами також з вами щоб не важливо в
якому куточку нашої країни педагоги
знаходяться наш ресурс не був тільки
ресурсом Lego foundtion а ставав
надбанням кожного педагога і щоб дійсно
ці всі ресурси знаходилися на відстані
одного кліка є розроблений збірник
активностей який допомагає
соціально-емоційному розвитку та
соціальній адаптації дітей а також
збірник ігрових онлайн взаємодій для
дошкільнят в якій також є на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України це
все для дошкільної освіти Окрім цього ми
підготували спільно із mhpsss cleberтів
такий курс психосоціальної підтримки
дітей та педагогів закладів дошкільної
та загальної середньої освіти який
називається благополуччя дітей та
педагогів дієві інструменти та практики
тривалість курсу може бути різна
модальність формат курсу також може бути
різна але особливістю цього курсу є те
що він базується на засадах ігрового і
діяльністьного під прикладів і
спрямований на надання
педагогів-інструментів взаємодії з
дітьми і реагування на їхні потреби у
контексті сьогодні але ресурсно для
педагогів для дітей Ми можемо стати
тільки тоді коли ми самі перебуваємо в
ресурсі тому перед усім Цей курс також
про те яким чином педагог може
потурбуватися про себе такий же курс
буде доступний і для вчителів загальної
середньої освіти загальна середня освіта
у нас також на часі Будемо продовжувати
з нею працювати І ще згадаю один момент
про дошкілля це випуск спеціальної
програми розвитку дитини від 2 до 6
років творці майбутньої це програма вже
доступна для учасників проєкту сприяння
освіти Ця програма була поширена з
педагогами які знаходяться поза межами
України і педагогами інших країн світу
які працюють з українськими дітьми і
найближчим часом буде доступна також для
всього дошкілля України
в рамках нуш от сьогодні згадували
рівними влітку тісно працювали для
продовження тренінгів масової практики
вчителів продовжуємо далі тому з ким нам
ще не вдалося по співпрацювати будь
ласка Ми на зв'язку готові ділитися
матеріалами і знову ж таки хочу згадати
про ресурс для вчителів матеріали
ресурсні матеріали є дуже багато
розроблених матеріалів від першого до
четвертого класу якщо ми говоримо про
початкову школу цей проект та тематичні
тижні ранкові зустрічі
онлайн-офлайнформати
онлайн-курси які ми готові розміщувати
також на ваших ресурсах щоб вони ставали
якомога ближчими до вчителів ось
онлайн-курс онлайн-курси про які я
згадували знаходяться на платформі
Future вчителі з будь-якого куточку
світу можуть мати до нього доступ І далі
Те що для нас з вами найважливіше це
безпосередньо співпраця з вами оскільки
Саме з вами ми можемо забезпечити сталі
стійкість тих ініціатив якими спільно з
вами розпочинали і ті спецкурси які
реалізовувались діяльність на підхід
початковій школі педагогіка гри у
закладі дошкільної освіти Ми їх
продовжуємо реалізувати будемо залучати
усіх вас але також і заклади вищої
освіти на сьогодні таких В нас співпраці
34 де ми імплементуємо у програму у
освітній програмі за спеціальностями
дошкільна освіта і початкова освіта
імплементуємо двохрічні
курси із діяльнісного навчання і ігрової
взаємодії з дітьми цілісний поступ
освітньої системи на сьогодні неможливий
без особливої уваги до дітей з
особливими освітніми потребами тому в
новому навчальному році ми фундація Lego
додаємо ще цей компонент до нашої
співпраці із українською системою освіти
і сьогодні мала мала розмову із
організацією економічного
співробітництва і розвитку і така
ключова думка Вектор думки який пролунав
про те що те що на сьогодні відбувається
в Україні насправді стане одним з
унікальних кейсів на всьому світовому
освітянському просторі і стане
натхненням і ресурсом для тих країн які
потребуватимуть відновлення освітніх
систем на віртуальному рівні Про що цей
кейс цей кейс про віру і незламність про
Партнерство і співпрацю провізію і
реалізацію про продовження розпочатого
ініціювання кардинально нового про
пришвидшення потрібно але в той же час
про відмову від зайвого про прийняття
вкрай складних але в довготривалій
перспективі необхідних рішень і
завершуючи сесію сьогодні Оскільки ми
дуже багато говоримо про ресурс хочу щоб
зараз кожен з вас знайшов три секундочки
подумати про те мій ресурс у
чому ресурс кожного з вас пам'ятайте Не
забувайте Повертайтеся до нього бо ми
потрібні діти дітям ми потрібні нашій
країні і як би складно не було
пам'ятаємо ми не самі в нас велика
спільнота і в цьому наша сила тому
діємо спільно задля поступу в реаліях
сьогодення дякую
пані Оксана дякую Шановні колеги
як ви бачили програму нашого Заходу
вичерпалася Я хочу перш за все
вибачитися за те що я не зупиняв в наших
колег тому що є можливість сказати своє
бачення поділитися своєю практикою і
просто поспілкуватися з нами тому що
вони часто ми так збиралися тому що я
думаю що ми вибачимо їх що вони
перебрали трохи регламент і ми лишній
час з вами попрацювали Шановні колеги
Хтось ще бажає виступити
немає
тоді дякую Шановні колеги за
результатами проведеної нашої локації Ми
повинні сформувати проект рішення для
формування цього фінального документу
слід пропозиції ви надіслати ми вам
скинемо посилання і яка яка допустим
буде така форма і він надійшло ти і нам
і ми спільноту допрацюємо для того щоб
подати в Міністерство про роботу нашої
локації я Всім дякую
хочу побажати всім мирного неба вам
вашим родинам щоб
швидше Закінчилася війна щоб наші діти
не чули вибухів бомб і свисту куль щоб
ми повернулися до навчання у мирній
нашій Україні
Слава Україні
Дякую і до побачення дякую